learn how to use pandas for data
analysis and data science in this full
course for beginners you will learn
pandas by example from Santiago he is an
experienced developer and he also
created one of the most popular data
analysis courses on the internet so you
are in good hands let's get started
hello my name is Santiago and this is
pandas by example a collaboration
between free code camp and data Wars I'm
originally from Argentina world
champions of the 2022 football or soccer
World Cup and why I'm telling you this
well as any other Argentinian I've
watched and played football pretty much
my entire life and you know what I have
learned that you don't get better at
playing football just by watching games
on TV this is obvious right to become a
better footballer you have to go out and
practice the same applies for data
science or any other analytical
discipline just watching videos doesn't
make you an expert you have to practice
and put your skills to a test that's
exactly what we're trying to do at
dataworks dataworks is a platform 100
focused on practicing data science and
applying your skills with real life
projects there are no videos just
projects to resolve with bite size
activities that you can check at each
stage of the process the best part is
that it's entirely free and will explain
you how to sign up in just a bit and
this is also the reasoning behind this
by example Series this video focuses on
resolving real projects brainstorming
And discussing the solutions and the
pitfalls along the process we'll
encourage you to try to solve the
projects by yourself first even pause
the video before we reveal the solutions
we want you to put your skills to a test
and challenge yourself this video covers
all the most important aspects of data
management with pandas including data
analysis data cleaning and data
wrangling each project focuses on a
different topic and the complexity grows
from start to finish we have separated
each project as a chapter and you can
jump back and forth as we've mentioned
before we encourage you to pause the
video and try to resolve each activity
by yourself first you can find a list of
all the projects we are resolving and
the instructions to sign up at
datawars.io free code camp with all that
said let's just get started solving
projects right now
in this project we're going to be
practicing our skills dealing with
pandas data frames we're gonna be doing
some selection understanding index
selection we're going to be creating a
new column and we're gonna do some
statistical summarization methods and
finally we're gonna do some question
answering by creating conditionals okay
so like selection based on different
conditions or queries that we want to
write so
um this is kind of on the simpler side
for this series we're just getting
started with data frames again doing
statistical methods some selection by
the index creating a column doing some
conditionals and that's it if you feel
comfortable with these topics just move
ahead to other sections of the videos
you we get a little bit more gets a
little bit more challenging as usual I'm
going to encourage you to just pause the
video before each activity and try to
resolve it by yourself so you can gain
some of that up application of the
skills right worst case scenario you can
just resume the video and take a look at
the way I resolved it and by the way
they're going to be different ways of
resolving these things these activities
so you might even stumble upon something
new that you do by yourself and I do
something different and that can be a
very rich experience so let's get
started
this data frame the the data set we're
using is a data set containing a big
list of English words and the index is
going to be the word itself and we're
going to talk about the index in a
second and then we have two columns
chart counts or character counts and the
value of the word the character account
that's easy is just the length of the
word that's it and the value is computed
by adding up all the individual values
of each character and the individual
values are just defined in this way so a
is one B is 2 C is three Etc so in this
case it's one plus one uh one plus one
plus the value of H which I don't know
where is H 10 11 whatever actually we
know it is um eight because this is one
plus one is two uh and the value is 10
so H is probably the or the a the
character number eight
and that's it this is already given so I
have already read the data frame and
we're going to get started with some
activities the important piece about
this data frame is that the index is the
word like the words themselves make the
index so whenever we want to access a
given word we can just do it by the
index and this is why it's so important
to understand how indices work in Panda
so let's get started right off the band
with the first activity which is how
many elements does this data frame have
there are multiple ways of answering
that the first one is with the info
method which is one of the most common
ones pretty quickly we go with info and
it gives us an understanding of the
index it tells us that the index just an
index with entries that go from a a
and that's it to these word which I
don't know what it means and we have a
total of one thousand one 172
821 words we can also use the shape
method this gives us kind of the shape
of the of the Matrix if you want in the
data frame and of course the values are
the same so we're going to plug this one
in and see how it goes there you go it
worked
okay moving forward what is the value of
the word this thing that I'm not gonna
even pronounce and this is a very
interesting activity
because remember we're gonna be doing
selection by index so as the index is
the word itself I can just use the Dot
Lock method and this should be familiar
DOT log that does index selection so we
can just pass whatever value I want for
an index using the Dot Lock method and
that's going to give me the result in
this case it gives me the the row itself
the entire row so we did like this row
selection but the result is in a series
so the projection to put in a way the
result of row selection which is kind of
horizontal structure is gonna be a
vertical structure which is a series
right you see the shaping right the the
the the
transposing operations like we go from
something that is a row to something
that is a series and it's not pretty
special don't pay too much attention to
it just to to to refer to the fact that
row is represented as a series and here
we can see that the value of this word
is
317. something also very convenient if
you're doing selection
is that the df.log method and we're
going to increase here the size tf.log
accepts two parameter the index
selection and then the columns right
why is that imagine that we have 100
columns it's going to be very hard to
just you know browse scroll to the value
we're looking for we can just pause here
what the column we want to use in this
case we're going to use value right
there and the value is 317. so let's go
ahead and try it
and it worked as expected
what is the highest possible value of a
word DF
at uh dot we're going to use two methods
let me show you once again the data
frame
what is the highest possible value we
can do DF at Value and do a Max method
right that's going to give us the
maximum value there or we can just do
df.mox to ha to have the max statistical
method computed for the whole data frame
right in this case we see again that the
value 319 or something that is pretty
common is do DF dot describe
and this method is just going to give
you this crib there we go oh
autocompleted
It's Gonna Give You summer statistics of
all your numeric columns in this case we
only have two columns and both are
numeric so we're good and it gives you
summar statistics of all the values
right there so for example the average
value the average
chart counts you know the the minimum
value the maximum value for character
count the maximum value for Value
Etc it's going to give us some summary
statistics so I think we have multiple
methods we're gonna go here with 319 and
submit the activity and that worked
now the next one which of the following
words have a Char count of seven and a
value of 87 and this is pretty
interesting because in the way we did
selection before and I'm gonna copy this
thing
right here we the way we did it before
was just by passing one value of the
index we were we worked with just one
word but selection in pandas the F Dot
Lock here
takes potentially a list of index values
to retrieve so here instead of asking
just one value I can pass each one of
them and there's going to be a little
bit of an annoying procedure I'm going
to just copy and paste all the words
here you feel free to fast forward I
will not copy this one because it
definitely has more than seven
characters just gonna you know quickly
and see which ones have seven characters
I think this one has more than seven
characters but doesn't matter let's add
it anyways
and now you can see that with df.log you
can actually pass multiple indices if
you want to get multi-selection or just
one you're gonna select just one
individual row and to answer the
activity
which of the following words have a
charcon of seven and a value of 87 it's
glowing right here we can just put here
glowing and submit and that worked just
a comment as we were doing before the
the first element in this case is that
list is the list of indices to select
the second one could potentially reaches
the column so here I could say value for
them oh I missed a square bracket and I
just get the value for each one of these
rows of course in this activity we did
both the Char count and the value so
that's why I didn't do it but just a
clarification
so what is the highest possible length
of a word we did it before with this cry
we're gonna do it
again and chart out the maximum one
seems to be 28.
there you go moving on to the next
section which is exploring interesting
words so
we did before this activity that was
that the this word that I'm not gonna
pronounce is the only word with the
value of 3 17. find the only word with
the value of 3 19. and there are
multiple ways of solving this one we
could let's let's say we do some sorting
first it's not going to be the most
effective way but let's do some sorting
let's see if I can put everything in the
same frame
um DF at df.sort values by
and volume it's going to be I'm going to
see ascending false
in this case as this word was the
one with the highest value just by
sorting we were able to reach that
result but of course that is not always
the case what happens if here it it's
asking us for
um for I don't know the value of
18 and that is clearly or even worse 50.
it's clearly in the middle I have to
just you know browse the data frame to
find the correct answer
in this case what we need to do is some
selection we need to do DF at I'm going
to do the whole syntax and we're going
to explain it later dot lockdf at value
is going to be 3 19. and this is the
first idea of conditional selection in
pens we have the word I'm going to just
plug it in see if it worked and if we
have a good activity there we go it
worked now how does this thing work
remember that
um whenever I assume you have worked
with this before whenever you have these
operations in pandas
um and if you haven't check out some
other simpler projects we have in the
platform that explain this in more
detail the ideas we are performing this
operation that returns a Boolean array
right so again refer to the projects in
the platform we have you know very very
thorough step-by-step process to explain
these topics but basically this creating
a Boolean volume as saying select this
word select this word or select this
word and indicating if we want to
retrieve it or not with a false True
Value so in this case we don't want the
a a word we don't want the a a h word
Etc but the ones that fulfill or match
this condition will have a True Value
here in this case is a long a Boolean
array is a
172 000 Boolean element Boolean array
and there's just one true volume which
is the one for this work so once this
Boolean array is resolved to put it away
in memory we pass that Boolean right to
Dot Lock method
that's Returns the value so here is to
kind of wrap it up with this idea of Dot
Lock we have three ways of doing Dot
Lock we can pass just one value as we
did before
the index right we can pass several
values for that match the index or we
can pass a full Boolean Ray indicating
which elements which rows we want to
select by just putting a false or a true
value
one tiny comment that's kind of a
question we receive all the time is that
is this efficient we could have resolved
this thing with just iterating on not
using any memory to put in a way because
at the end of the day we have to create
this Boolean Ray we're just gonna set in
memory and then we do the selection
based on that Boolean rate so the
question is why are we gonna create this
intermediate Boolean array if we could
just you know it rate it right I can do
something like uh four row in
DF if row at Value equals 319 print row
just to put away in reality I have to
also use the index but anyway in this
case I'm just doing a more imperative
way of resolving this activity and I'm
not using any memory I'm just the data
frame is data frame there's existing
memory I create an auxiliary slot just
for this particular row and this seems
to be more efficient but the reality is
that these Boolean rays are actually
very very tiny they might look like they
are these huge
huge you know series which all these
string values but in reality these are
just ones and zeros so it's a very small
one bit element array right and the
index is pretty much same with we have
so uh just a comment on the side and I
want to get to technical but again the
beauty of paying the selections this Dot
Lock Works by the index and again we can
pass just one value multiple values or a
full Boolean array
all right moving forward what is the
most common value
um
to answer this question we can refer
back to I'm going to do value scribe
there you go and we can do
um different statistical methods right
so in this case we have the main
standard deviation minimum maximum Etc
we also have the median which is right
here which is the value 103 and there is
one that is not showing up here
which is the mode of the
um of the given series or a given array
so we can got we can we could have an
understanding of the statistical method
so we're going to do something like DF
at Value mode
and we get that 93 is the most common
value now this doesn't tell you much
because it just tells you of all the
different values we have in our data
frame let's do that
93 is enough the value that shows up the
most times and we don't know in which
situations because the character count
might be different but there are
different characters so the value is
different but a very common method
something that I use all the time is the
DF at Value and we're going to do value
counts method this is a very very
helpful I get just the first ones
um a very helpful method is going to
give you
this given value
appears
1965 times so 100 as activity said is
the second most common volume and there
are
um 100 well there are
1921 words that match that volume
the value 93 is the most common one and
there are
1965 words that much that given value
right here
um we could do something like DF Dot
Lock DF at the value
equals uh 93 and we can get here let's
get the first 10
all these words
get
um or have the same value even though
they have different
um different
chart counts right because they have
different
um characters let me do sample here so
we get a random sample of values so
right here we have for example ingests
have seven characters and has the value
is 93 again the sum of the characters
results in 93 but let's do it again I'm
gonna keep that one there
um the testable has 10 characters and
has the same value right so again to
compute the mode
of a of values you can use the use the
mode
um statistical method or for me most
common
um very useful is the value counts
method gives you not just the most
common value gives you kind of a ranking
of the most common values in a in a
column and also gives you how many
samples you can find of that value
all right so oh we haven't done it let's
see if it passes 93 is our most common
value there you go it worked what is the
shortest word with the value 274. let's
resolve that now
um DF uh we're gonna do a little bit of
selection first so let me align that so
we can zoom in
what is the shortest word with the value
to 74. so first we can start by
selecting all the words with a value of
there we go and then what we could do is
either sort values
um by
Char count
and this is going to be the shortest one
or
we could have done a little bit of more
selection I think that
um
just by doing this method it works we
could have done something like we get
the value the Char count sorry
here so we have that
um
only the given column and then we get
the minimum value right so what's the
minimum value 20. with this thing we
could have also extended our query and
do df.lock
um I'm gonna do that and
this and the
the
df.log no DF at
chart count is equals to 20 that's the
one we got before and this is equal to
that
and
there we go we can do a very quick
selection we could have done it also in
a way that it's Dynamic so we get plug
this value here
and this is all the same thing at the
end of the day I think that just you
know if we don't have too many elements
sorting the values is an easier way to
resolve it so let's go ahead and do it
there we go by the way this is something
that we do you know in production to put
in a way like in our day-to-day jobs all
the time sometimes you will need to
build more Dynamic Solutions but
sometimes you're just doing some
analysis just exploring data you know
you can keep it easy just you know with
the different methods you can hear the
important pieces applying the right
technique for the right problem
all right moving forward
next activity this is interesting create
a column ratio which represents the
value ratio of a word which is defined
as the value of the word divided by the
cards or counts so let's do that right
now stop me if you want to practice this
by yourself but the way to create these
ratios is going to be let me show you
the F first the head
is gonna be DF at ratio that's the name
that it's asking us
um the column is asking us is going to
be equals to DF at
um value divided by DF by chart count
and now we're gonna we're gonna do this
thing again and we have a ratio computed
right here the value divided by the
chart counts let's check to see if it
works
it did work we are good to keep moving
forward so a few more questions what is
the maximum value of ratio DF at ratio
dot Max
22.5
um what word is the one with the highest
ratio and here multiple ways to solve it
again sort of values I think is a good
alternative I'm going to do buy ratio
but here let's do it right here this in
this way
by defaults our values is sorting in
ascending mode we actually want it
flipped we want to start you know with
the highest one at the top so we're
going to pass ascending equals false
we're going to pass this order and now
we have that the highest ratio is 22.5
um what word is the one with the highest
ratio
um
22.5 the word is x u
um as we know the highest ratio we could
also have rate and a query df.lock or DF
at ratio is equals to the maximum ratio
and that is also XU is the same result
so again two different ways of resolving
the same activity it's important for you
to have all the techniques in your tool
belt then which ones you use it depends
on what problem you are solving
words have a ratio of 10 so what we can
do here is we can do DF we could have
done
this is not going to work so well value
counts let's get an idea of the values
and here we have just this was this we
were very lucky that 10 is a common
enough value that there are 2600 words
with it and we can see it but if this
was not such a common value the the the
ratio that we're looking for it's
probably you know buried in this sea of
different ratios because there are
actually 1 333 different ratios so as
ratio is a Continuum variable you know
there are multiple individual points
it's usually not convenient to use value
accounts
instead what we want to do is just write
a simple query DF Dot Lock all the rows
that have a ratio of
10 right that's the where you want to
build gives us a bunch of
rows what we can do is just do a shape
and that's going to give us the same
number that we have right here we're
going to plug it
in here let's do a quick quick stop here
an asterisk to mention the dot query
method so df.log and all this selection
is usually the prefer method because
it's the most powerful one but sometimes
you just want to use
the query method that is just kind of a
shorthand you can write it in plain
English it's kind of
python based and the query method is
just works in this way we can say ratio
equals 10 and it's relatively simple
you can use it whenever you have like
simple conditions there you go here's
for you to compare I personally myself I
usually prefer this method but that's
because I'm just very used to it and I
like thinking in terms of pulling arrays
and campaigning combining Boolean arrays
and all that up to you if you want to
use Query the one that suits you better
moving forward what is the maximum value
of all the words with a ratio of 10. so
we're gonna keep let's keep query here
this is the results and what we can do
here is we can sort values let me put in
context again activity what is the
maximum value sort of values
by value
value
ascending false
and here
we can find what is a maximum value of
all the words with a ratio of 10 right
head there you go we had
um what is the maximum value 240 it
seems
um we could have also done
here actually for this particular
solution I think this method is going to
be better we can do
thoughts and we're gonna do value
just get the max
we should get the same result 240 and
that's the same answer here the beauty
of sore values that sometimes you see
like the data in this case you have to
trust it which is fine we have an
analytical resolution we we can't trust
it but in this way like you can trust it
like the radio stand charging is 24 the
value is 20 240 it's it's usually a
little bit I don't know it it leaves you
at peace to see that the data is okay
um let's keep moving forward
of those words with a value of 216. what
is the lowest uh Char count found in
this case we have pretty much the same
thing uh we're gonna do here
DF let's do query now and we're going to
do of those words with the values 260 so
value is 216.
what is the lowest charcon found so
first this thing is going to give you
all the words with the value of 260 and
now we can sort
values
by chart count
and that's going to give us
um what is the lowest chart gone found
is 17 so here we're gonna find 17.
there you go and the last activity we're
going to be done based on the previous
task what word is it this is the word
and we are good to go one important one
minimum comments
um about the query method and we're just
gonna wrap it up with these particular
projects is that when you're when you're
um
columns have
um spaces you need to
surround them in back text so let's get
let's invent a new activity just by
ourselves here very quickly I'm gonna
use this crib there you go I say
um let's say I'm just writing this on
the Fly
um find all the words
with chart count
greater than the mean or the average
Char counts chart counts yeah cards are
counts right so these activities were
like just making up on the Fly
how can we first we can compute and
let's say we have
um we're gonna mean
chart counts gonna be count it's gonna
be dot mean and we're gonna print it
I'm going to show you how to write the
query using this variable we're going to
do df.query
um where chart accounts
and this is not gonna work
is greater than 9 right so this is not
going to work because there are spaces
you have to surround them with tactics
that's the first thing you want to learn
the second thing is if you want to
reference this variable in here if I do
this that's not going to work either
just gonna blow up
because by default anything that is a
name within this query is going to
reference a column so if you want to
reference an external variable what you
have to do is pass here the Ampersand uh
symbol in this case gonna say give me
all the values in which this column
surrounded by bug text so respect the
the white space
is greater than this thing and this
thing is referencing an external
variable so go out to put it away to the
global scope or local whatever and find
this value plug it in and run the query
and here is what we can do right there
so again the query method is convenient
I personally myself I prefer to use
The Dot Lock method I like to combine it
with column selection I like to think in
terms of boiling arrays but it's
perfectly fine to use Query just
remember this uh tricks right that
sometimes you're going to need to use
backticks for columns with white spaces
and you can reference external firewalls
with the ad symbol that is it with data
frames let's keep moving forward and
solving more projects applying those
data science skills
in this project we're going to practice
how to filter data sort it do some
selections some querying all very useful
data analysis techniques the data that
we're going to be working with is a data
set containing Pokemon information
including their type their stats some
total attack defense and all that their
generation and their legendary status so
let's go ahead and just read the data to
get started and we're going to start
working with activities one by one as
usual just pause if you want to resolve
it by yourself and then you're gonna
hear me with the explanation what I'm
going to try doing in this project or
for this project is giving you all the
different possibilities we can think of
so Solutions with DOT block Solutions
with ilock if that applies and also
Solutions with the dot query method
the first thing you have in this
notebook is a little bit of an
information in terms of distribution of
the Pokemons we have so for example
these are all the type 1 Pokemon
Pokemons and you also we also have some
analysis of for example the stats so for
example total we see that there are a
few very powerful Pokemons
um both in terms of a histogram and a
box spot so all these visualizations are
usually pretty useful right when you are
starting your data analysis with a new
data set you just do a quick
visualization of how your data is
distributed in terms of for example
category categorical variables how they
are assigned or also the ranges
distribution of some numeric variables
like in this case the total ones to see
we we can see the most powerful Pokemons
in this case there are legendary status
we can also consider a categorical
variable
and on that let's get started with the
activities one by one so how many
Pokemons exist with an attack uh value
greater than 150 right so let's take a
look at the data first that's what we're
dealing with and we're gonna Focus how
many Pokemons exist with an attack found
if greater than 150 so let's get started
pause if you want and we're going to do
df.log DF Arts
attack
greater than 150 right
that's going to give us the full list of
Pokemons with that attack and we can
kind of see that there weren't like too
many with that value already with the
fox plot with the query itself we can
get a real sense of how many Founders we
have in this case we have just three we
could also do something like shape to
get it but again we can clearly see that
there are only three samples that match
that given condition we can also do the
query method so I can do DF dot query
where attack is greater than 150 and we
get the same results so let's try it out
see
there you go it worked correct
move forward select all the Pokemons
with a speed of 10 or less so in this
case we need to create a sub data frame
so it says right here store your results
in slow Pokemons DF so in this case is a
speed of 10 or less so that's that's
gonna be pretty pretty slow it's right
below here we have probably 10. it's
gonna be a pretty small amount of
Pokemon so let's take a look first how
many fulfill that condition
PDF at Miss type speed is uh
is 10 or less so this is less or equals
and 10. and we have only a handful one
two three four five
um and we can of course assign that to
this variable to have a final check with
activity let's do it on the side in
parallel there you go it worked
and of course using dot query it's query
speed is less or equals than 10. from
now on I will try to stick to the Dot
Lock method is the one that I prefer
um instead of using query but you know
you can use either I prefer to work with
pool in arrays remember this expression
is going to be just a Boolean expression
right so how many of these values are
the values are true are basically
that the values that match the given
condition this is pretty useful if we
want to count the values and this is
something I could have done in the
previous one which I didn't realize
showing before basically if I did
something like this dot sum I'm going to
get the same result right how many
values in this full array so arrays and
that is it attack is an array let's say
a series a collection that has integers
and then we ask give me an array a
Boolean array of all the ones that match
this condition this case greater than
150 so it's going to be false false
false false false and of course when I
have three in this huge Ray that are
true so in this case as I told you
in the previous project we did with
English words if the array in this case
it seems that they are just you know
strings saying false and true in reality
this is a Boolean array so in reality
these are all ones and zeros very
efficient very compact array ones and
zeros we can sum that and we have the
final result in this case we can count
we can sum write all the ones we have
just three ones and that gives us the
answer to the previous question as well
all right moving forward
um how many let's hear how many Pokemons
have a sp death value special defense
value of 25 or less
um special ability defense so we're
gonna do
df.log how many Pokemons have a special
defense value of 25 or less I'm gonna do
DF at sp.dev
less or equals than 25 because again
it's value of 25 or less and now we have
a bunch so now we can use the technique
that we did before that is just this dot
sum I'm gonna criticize here a bit
and we have 17 as a result I could have
done the same thing here shape and I get
pretty much this table has 17 rows
of course this is a little bit more
compact let's say easier so let's try it
out 17 and see if it works there you go
it worked we're good to go and keep
moving progress it's making progress so
select all the legendary Pokemons this
is pretty interesting one we have to
store the result select only Pokemons
that are legendary
and sort the result in the variable
legendary dot legendary DF so that's
going to be df.log DF at legendary but
let's take a look first using the info
method let's take a look at the
legendary column the legendary column
itself is a Boolean column A Boolean
series given by its type so that means
that
it is itself a Boolean array with true
and false values we could ask the effort
legendary how many Legendary Pokemons we
have in this data set and that's just
the sum of the legendary status that's
it because this is a Boolean array so
remember if we did DF odds attack for
example greater than 150 and we had this
huge Boolean Ray falls through falls
through and then we selected the ones
that had a True Value we can pretty much
do the same thing here and what I'm
gonna do is we could say something like
this thing is true right so give me all
the legendary Pokemons uh what did I do
wrong
um
false cannot oh Boolean index DF is
equals
there you go my bad
is equals to true but the reality is
that this column itself is a Boolean
array so let's just get rid of the true
and we say select all the on the
Pokemons that are legendary just dots
just pass the mask the Boolean mask and
perform the selection if we want it
let's say we wanted to get all the
Pokemons that are not legendary the not
the non-legendary Pokemons we can of
course do something like false
we're going to get how many we have
but the reality is we can just invert
the array we had false false true false
right those are original array we can do
inversion of this thing negate it with a
this operator that's going to give us
true true
false true this is false so what I can
do is I can just do the negation here
and I get the same result
so sorry I got a little bit sidetracked
what we want to get is all the Pokemons
that are of Type legendary and to do
that we're gonna assign that to this
variable
and we're gonna get the head first five
rows there you go all legendary and
let's check if the activity passes
this is why it's so important to
understand the column types of your data
because sometimes you know the
selections or the Boolean arrays you're
going to be working with are not the
same depending on the type of the data
you you have okay moving forward find
the outlier so we have
this distribution of Pokemons and we
have to find this particular one the one
that has a defense value that is pretty
big and also an attack value that it's
pretty low right so this
Pokemon has a ton of Defense but a very
low attack of course we could do
something like BF a defense
uh dot sort let's let's let's do let's
do the after hand show the whole thing
then we're gonna do DF dot sort values
by
defense
and
show the first few
by default the Sorting method is in
ascending mode so we are starting in
this way we're going in this direction
we want to invert that we're going to do
ascending equals false so now we have
the strongest ones here
and here we have the one that has a
defense of 230 and an attack right of in
this case uh attack here of 10. this
pretty much gives us the the answer
right away let's actually try it out
let's see if this is the one this is the
Pokemon that activity requests at least
for this particular value it is that
past but I want to make a comment here
that you can you can actually sort by
multiple
um by multiple criteria we could also
say something that sort by defense first
and then as a second criteria sort by
attack
there you go and then for defense we
want it to be in descending mode so
ascending is false but for attack we
want it to be in ascending mode again
the result is the same because the data
it's pretty clear who is this
um outlier right here but again the
understanding is we can sort by multiple
criteria what's going to happen is that
the Sorting starts here
and then we're gonna sort by attack in
the other direction we can combine as
many as we want of this criteria right
here
um all right moving forward more
activities now we're gonna get into
advanced selection with some Boolean
conditions how many Firefly Pokemons are
there so we want type 1 equals equals
fire and type 2 equals flying so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna do df.log
and up here again pause if you want
we're gonna do a little bit of Boolean
operators the first condition is going
to be
DF odds uh type 1 is equals to fire
right and the second condition and how
many do we have
the second condition is that type 2
has to be flying flying
there you go but what we want is the
combination of both type 1 fire and type
2 flying the way to do that is to
combine them
with an operator an ampersand operator
so I'm gonna break it into different
lines here
and I'm going to put the operator right
here so you see the conditions
how many
fireflying Pokemons are there seems like
we only have five let's try the result
first and then we're gonna explore a
little bit more the
the data frame resulting and as you can
see I haven't even looked at a single
Pokemon what I'm doing is just combining
conditions and summing Bull in arrays so
this is a pretty interesting thing
because what is happening here is like
let's say we had only five Pokemons in
total right we have
um and and we have the first array here
is gonna say type is is fire and the
second array is going to be is uh flying
right and we had something like true
true false
true false so this is of type fire type
fire not type fire yes type fire not
type fire and then for flying we had
false true false false false there we go
so in this case this is the only flying
Pokemon
what happens and that's why we have like
different results of course we had here
A bunch of fire Pokemons and here we
have a cup of a bunch of flying Pokemons
we have True Values for the condition
but what happens when you we use these
Ampersand is that we do one by one bit
by bit Boolean Bali by Boolean value we
do the operation the Ampersand operation
which is like the and operation in
Python so we do true
and falls for the first one so the first
one can be true on false what is the
result of true unfolds false
and what there we do the result of true
and true what is the result of true let
me show you true and false is of course
false true untrue is true
so we have that false and false is false
true and false again is false and we
could say this one was true false and
true is false there you go so in an and
operation and we have Opera operator one
and operator two or operand operand one
and operand two for this expression for
this whole thing for this whole
expression to be true
both op1 and op2
must
put it this way must be true
for this operation to be true
anything else either op1 is false or op2
is false or both are false anything else
anything else is false this is just some
Boolean arithmetic
um Boolean operation operators just you
know a little bit of that applies to
python as well but the interesting thing
is that that is same operation we're
seeing here are comp comparison bit by
bits value by value and line is what
we're doing right here
so we had 47 Pokemons were of type 1
fire and we had 89 Pokemons were of type
to Flying and then we combined those
things using an ampersand an and
operation and the result was only five
Pokemons so we can we can actually
visualize those sample points we're
going to do Dot Lock
and we're going to pass that condition
at these are the only five Pokemons are
of type one fire and type 2 flying okay
because we are using this Boolean
operators
okay moving forward
how many Pokemons oh there are one thing
one thing if we wanted to use a query
method we could have Rewritten this
thing with query and we're gonna do
remember that if you have white spaces
in your column names you have to
surround that with uh backticks in this
case gonna be fire
and
type 2
type 2 equals flying
and I made a mistake here flying should
be a string there you go we have the
final result so again this is this is
easier to type probably we need to put
the bug text in the column that has a
white space and here we can just use
Python and we can use a string you have
to make sure you're not you're matching
or on the contrary you don't matching
um the strings the string quotes use
you're using to surround the whole
expression
um and then we within the Boolean
operators we use the regular python ones
we don't use the and percent we use just
the and when we are using Dot Lock form
we must use the Boolean operators R and
or a not
and if we're doing something here uh let
me see if I can do knots yes we can do a
node right here as well
okay now moving forward
um activity number seven how many poison
Pokemons are across both types so as you
can see
right here
um the type of a Pokemon is a Pokemon
has two types let's say it has a strong
type and a and a secondary type
the type poison can be applied to either
the primary type or the secondary one
because I can actually show you that you
type one
counts
we have that there are poison 28
Pokemons that have poison in type 1 and
type 2
there are where is it not 31 Pokemons
that have poisonous secondary type so we
want to basically say or find how many
poisonous Pokemons are there in general
right how many poisonous Pokemons we can
find in either time so the expression
and let's start now with a query method
so you can visualize it first so it's
going to be type 1
equals poison
or
type 2 equals
poison
and there you go how many do we have
here let's let's copy this thing and do
a shape to get the final result how many
28 it seems
the wrong answer
um we can check that in a second
I can try using the Dot Lock oh no no no
wait wait it's just typo here
59 let's try 59.
there you go it worked so it's just a
typo
um but let's now think about it
in terms of the Dot Lock method
the way it works is pretty much the same
thing we did before DF of type 1 equals
equals uh poison
right this is going to give us a Boolean
array
and we can combine that Boolean array
which pretty much the same expression
which is Type 2 points but here what we
want to do is an or operation and the
way it works is let's say we have let's
see if I didn't delete there we go our
previous race
we're gonna use them again here
nowhere
here
so let's say we have poison
poison type 1 and type 2.
the way it's gonna work now is as this
is an or expression we care for any of
the samples so if this Pokemon is
poisoned here or here doesn't doesn't
matter we want to retain that object so
if it's true here or here we want to
still make the whole thing a true
operation that's the result of doing
true or false for example or doing false
or true right as we did before and I can
let me delete this thing and go back to
our previous notes we said that if we
have these two operations
that it's op1 operand one and operand
two and I'm still in the end sorry for
the back and forth but let's start again
let's pick up where we were before with
the N operator
this thing is going to be true only
if both operands are true so op1 and op2
must be true and this is and operation
op1 and op2 must be true
for this whole thing to be true any
other case everything is false
we can do a very similar reasoning with
a poor operation so
op1 or op2
must be
false both of them for this thing to be
false
anything else is true
and this is you can just flip things and
that just works that's that's the idea
between Boolean algebra you can just
flip things true with false in this case
true or false
or false or true true or true all these
things will be true the only way to get
out false result back is by both these
things being false
I'm going to get into our logic here we
say true or false is true and true and
true is true and to that we align false
and false is false right so these two
are false so this was fire flying so
it's not poison in this case it was po
it was Poison rock I'm just making up
types it was uh for example uh flying
poison right so that is also true so
true
and true
so what we're doing here with Dot Lock
we are
generating the the first Boolean array
and combining it with the second Boolean
array with the or operation and again
conceptually speaking it works in this
way
the result of this whole thing if we
wrap it in parenthesis and do a sum
we're gonna get the same value out
remember these are just pulling arrays
okay let's keep moving forward what uh
Pokemon of type 1 ice has the strongest
defense so we have to find
and you're gonna see that I usually
start my activities doing the F dot head
is because I need to take a look at the
structure of my data I'm going to do DF
uh Dot Lock
type one
type one sorry DF at type one
equals
ice I'm going to start in this way
so these are all the Pokemons that have
type 1 eyes now I can keep going by
doing something like give me the one
here we can do
um and the defense
dot Max
so the maximum difference of
um of type 1 ice pokemens is 184. I
could extend this one
by saying give me the Pokemons that are
type 1 ice and and here I'm going to use
an and operation because I want both
things to be true and DF at uh defense
is the maximum that I found before 184
and if you let me I'm gonna put
everything together and I could do that
and it's going to give me just one
Pokemon right so far so good let's put
it in here see if it works it works that
was the correct answer but now let me
show you something a little bit easier
in these cases we're looking for D1 like
the most powerful or the most powerful
like if we if we have several but we're
looking for a maximum volume what we
could have done is just sort values here
we're going to sort by defense
and we're going to sort in descending
order we want let me show you the
standard one it's going to show you the
uh the least powerful like the weakest
Pokemons first that's because this is
sorted by defense but in ascending mode
what I do is sorting descending mode to
do that we're going to do ascending
equals false
and now we get the most powerful the
same results as before which is of type
ice we have the the most powerful one
that we can see right here so this is a
more of a
visualization you know I'm doing some
analysis with my own eyes so I can just
you know get the first value here it's
not so programmatic this is a little bit
more programmatic I could automate this
thing and I can do something like
um
for example ilock
zero one and I have just the name of the
first Pokemon the name this is a little
bit more programmatic but again it's
pretty much the same thing as far as as
what what we're doing serves the same
purpose
okay keep moving forward what's the most
common type of legendary Pokemons what
is the most common type of legendary
Pokemons with the most common type one
from legendary Pokemon so what we can do
is let's first lock
all the Pokemons are legendary
and we did this before so this is going
to give us all legendary Pokemons and
now what we can do is to type one
this gives us the whole thing and now we
can do it just value counts
and we can get that psychic is the most
common type of Pokemons and let's do
that there
see if it works there you go you can
combine this thing kind bar
there we go to do a little bit of a
visualization but anyway the result is
correct the important thing here in
terms of filtering and all that is that
we filter by the legendary status which
is the Boolean array and then we passed
the type 1 column to get only that
column and then we got a summarization
using file accounts
okay what's the most powerful Pokemon
from the first three generations of type
water
so we need to find the effort head as
usual so we take a look at the structure
of our data
find the Pokemons the most powerful
Pokemon by total so we want to find the
total being the the powerful
representation here from the first three
generations that is of type water so
let's start step by step with different
with different uh conditions to find to
filter types of Pokemons are type water
that's simple we're gonna do df.log DF
at type one equals water uh
there we go
but now we have to combine it with the
expression
that is from any of the first three
generations how many generations we have
uh generation we're gonna do now value
counts we're gonna get there are
um we can actually
I think let me see let me see the
let me ask here
what's the syntax of the value counts
value counts method because what I want
to do
is
not sort these values we can visualize
it in a quick VAR chart to put it in a
way
Valley counts is the same
How can I
what parameters
does it accept
I'm closer to find the documentation of
pandas than
asking the AI here
there you go
um sort Falls this is the the one that I
was looking for so let's do sort Falls
there you go and now I'm gonna do plot
kind bar
there you go so these are the
generations we have one two three four
five six
um this is a little bit this is not
useful for the exercise in reality just
you know wanted to for you to take a
look at the generations basically what
it asking us to do
is uh the first three generations is
going to be generation one two and three
continue with our exercise
how can we get the Pokemons of the first
three generations the way to do that is
gonna be DF we could do something like
generation let me actually type it
outside we can do something like
generation equals one
or
uh
or two or three
and we wrap this whole thing
in parenthesis
dot sum
there we go
but the reality is that it's a much
easier method which is DF at generation
dot is in
so we're gonna pass here a collection
one two or three
we're going to get the same results so
it's basically the same expression as
before this value right here can take
any of these forms and that is good for
us
um
that is the same as doing uh this full
or so putting everything together what
we're gonna do is let me Zoom here and
we're gonna break this into several
lines we're gonna do type one is water
and
the generation is one two three
there you go and I already forgot what
the question was answering was the most
powerful Pokemon by total
here we're gonna sort values by total
and as usual
let me show you what it returns returns
in a ascending mode we actually want to
do it in descending mode so we're going
to do sort values
buy oh no no sorry we already did sore
values we're going to do ascending
false
and we're gonna get Kai or Kyogre my
English span and on top of Pokemon's
words
um is the most powerful Pokemon by far
um in terms of total so what can I pass
it value and see if it works I'm going
to do a quick summary the first one is
this idea where just as usual combining
um things with the Boolean array or
sorting values to get answer the
interesting part is we're using this is
in operator right that lets you pass uh
several of our values and it's basically
a simple way to write an or statement so
let's say we're going to get all the
Pokemons that are of type uh type one
either fire or water we can say is
saying and we can do here fire or water
so any Pokemons that are fire or water
it's basically this volume has to be in
this subsets
okay moving forward what's the most
powerful Dragon from the last two
generations this is getting interesting
so find the most powerful buy total that
is of type dragon ether type 1 or type 2
so ether type
from the last two generations and enter
its name below so it has to be a dragon
either in type 1 and talk to and from
the last two generation last two
generations we saw before the last the
generations are I already deleted it
basically generation value counts
there we go it's uh five and six are the
last two generations we're gonna write
the whole thing now
uh we're gonna do
we're gonna break it in lines oh let's
say DF at type one is dragon
um
or
the F at type 2 is dragon
and
DF at
uh
DF uh
generation
dot is in
and here we have the last two
generations those five or six and here
quick note we are I'm using here assets
you can pass a tuple a list whatever I
just pass an inline set because the most
correct way of doing it
um in terms of performance I don't think
it affects enough but it's just the
correct way of doing it but anyway in
terms of solving the activity let's go
ahead and the way we're going to do is
I'm gonna just run this thing we have to
find the most powerful Pokemon in this
in this set of being type 1 dragon type
2 dragon and this generation five or six
but you're gonna find something
interesting so I'm gonna show you
these results first let's see what did
we get
type
um it's type 1 dragon type
2 dragon that is good so let me show you
the data type one dragon type 2 dragon
so the first condition seems to be
matching but what you're gonna
immediately see is that the generation
is incorrect we get Pokemon from
generation one three four and that is
because we're combining the conditions
that it's either or this thing or and
this thing so the operators in the way
they work is that it did the operator of
this thing that works and then it did
the operation of these two things
but that is not what we're looking for
the way we want it to work is to perform
these two first it's either this either
one of these and this one in here so to
do so what we need is to surround these
two operations with parentheses so it's
like the order of the operations here is
important it's first perform this thing
it's either type 1 dragon or type 2
dragon and
we want it to be
generation six or five I don't know if
this syntax works there again it worked
um and now we can see that it's dragon
in type 1 dragon in type 2. and the
generation is only five and six so this
is the expression that we want to get
now
the only thing we need to do is sort
values by total
ascending false
and we get that these Pokemon is the
most powerful one type one dragon type 2
Electric that doesn't matter and it's
generation five so let's try the answer
right there
and it worked
okay moving forward and this is
important we we I don't think we have
another activity in this project that
has like the Precedence the importance
of the Precedence or the order of
operators but it's an important concept
um so just you know remember parentheses
don't hurt it's cheap to put parentheses
so if you have these complex Expressions
just make sure you're surrounding the
ones that you want to run first with
parentheses you can indent you can do
all sort of things as long as you know
it makes it look better for you could
have you something like that so is this
thing and this thing you know actually
prints are not necessary here anyway
just keep in mind the Precedence of the
operations is important
all right select the most powerful fire
type Pokemons so here
we're gonna say select all the Pokemons
that have an attack volume above 100
above and type one
equals to Fire and we're gonna do df.log
we can actually do a query now
we're going to oh by the way we can
solve this one with a query method first
so sorry let's go back to the previous
one if you are passing and resuming
you're hating me in this moment
basically we're gonna say
um we need prices here so type 1 equals
dragon
um or
type one two equals dragon
and
oh we can't do the in here we can we can
do the in so we can do generation in
five
or six
and we get oh we have to sort the values
and we have the same result let me break
this into multiple lines it's difficult
to read but anyway but you can see here
is we are producing pretty much the same
expression and the Order of Operations
is important type 1 dragon or type 2
dragon that's the first thing and
generation is in five or six
um let's see if it doesn't break when we
got this the wrong results
here when we remove the parenthesis you
can see that our Pokemons of generation
three one so this is clearly not working
have to go back and put the parenthesis
for the order so sorry now let's move
forward to the other one which was
select all the Pokemons with the attack
greater than 100 and type 1 equals fire
we're going to use a query we're gonna
do uh attack is greater than 100 because
it says above and type 1
um equals fire there we go we're gonna
run that thing and we're gonna assign it
to our variable
visualize it let's see if it works it
worked were correct
next one select all water type flying
type Pokemons so select all these
Pokemons that have type 1 for water and
type 2 flying
we're gonna do pretty much the same
thing as here we're gonna do VF
dot query we're gonna do type one water
and
type to
flying
and let's see the data we get back water
flying for both types and let's check
the activity
there we go
and finally well not finally there are
two three more but select specific
Columns of legendary Pokemons of type
fire okay so this is interesting pause
now you want to sold by yourself it says
performance selection in your data frame
of all legendary Pokemons that are of
Generation 1 type 1 type that are
of type 1 fire sorry but select Only The
Columns name attack and generation so
we're gonna do
the F DOT log we're going to use and
there's gonna be a good reason that our
um DF at type one
equals fire
and DF at legendary
that's the first result so type one fire
and legendary I switch the order here
but we don't want to get all the columns
we want to do just a selection we say we
only want the columns and here we're
going to say name
attack on generation
and
let me break this
these two modes so we get it and we get
the regular right tf.log
accepts
conditions for index
columns right so here we have and let's
actually do more parenthesis we don't
need them but let's do more parentheses
it's more clear of what we're trying to
do we need more parentheses there you go
so this is the condition and then it
comes the columns
um and the final result that we have
right here so type on fire and legendary
and the columns are name attacking
generation let's give it a try
and that worked as expected as well
select slow and fast Pokemon so this is
getting interesting now we're gonna see
what this visualization shows us so
select slow and fast Pokemons we're
going to get all the Pokemons take a
look at this region of Pokemon speed and
histogram including the notebook the red
lines separate this lowest bottom five
percent and the fastest top five percent
Pokemons
um right here so basically we create a
histogram and then we plot two red lines
in .05 and 0.95 so it's the 0.05 quart
quantile fifth percent and top 95th
percentiles and what we want to do is
basically select those Pokemons that are
either Above This 95 or below the five
percent the two extremes of the
distribution let's say so what we're
going to do is df.log
and we have the values by the way we can
actually take a look at them we can do
here let's actually do this thing
we're gonna do uh bottom five is this
thing top
5 is 95.
there we go
um and let's show both
top five
there you go so we know that the cutoff
for a very slow Pokemon is a valid 25
the cutoff to be considered very fast
Pokemon is 110. I'm going to use first
the deadlock method we're gonna do
DF at speed is
um less than because we want it to be
uh select
where where are we
the slowest Pokemon and the fastest
Pokemon is very slow with speed below
the bottom five or very fast Above Top
95 so we want it to be this operation
um or
and here's another one very fast so it's
going to be DF at speed is going to be
greater than top five
let's put this whole thing here
um slow fast Pokemon there we go these
are table and let's try it out first to
see if it worked there you go it works
but there is another way which is
basically using dot query method what
we're going to do is the F dot query and
you know this already speed is going to
be less than and here to reference an
external variable we've seen this
already we're going to use the amp the
add symbol
so on this thing we don't need
parenthesis or speed is greater than top
top 5 and we need the
there you go and we have the same result
68 rows 13 columns the same result you
can trust me but basically the important
Point here is we are using an external
variable and referencing it with the at
symbol right to reference something
outside of this particular query speed
references the column uh the at this
thing references an external variable we
have defined before
all right and I think we have the last
one and this is a very interesting one
as well
says take a look at this cutter plot
correlating defense to attack
what's the name of the Pokemon indicated
by the red arrow in the image below so
who's this guy right here it's a Pokemon
that has a strong defense and a strong
attack so what we can do is sort by both
values so we have like uh this case
first is legendary and second it has a
very strong tab attack and a very strong
defense so let's take a look the first
thing we're going to do is lock this
filter all the legendary Pokemons
uh legendary
and sort values we're gonna sort
by doing
um by
defense
and attack there you go by both those
criteria or actually we can swap it
uh defense so we take a look at it in a
more vertical way so we're gonna sort in
this way and then in this way and of
course we want to do ascending
false
and here we have
this Pokemon has an attack of 116 so
it's above this line
and a defense of 110 so it's kind of
right here
um in reality we're looking this for
this Pokemon that it's very close to 150
okay so let's keep moving forward we
have these Pokemon that has an attack of
115 so
again right here it matches and a
defense that is 140 so this one looks a
lot better let's try it out and see if
it works
we have our volume and there you go all
correct all complete but basically what
we're trying to do here is using this
combination of visualizations with the
um analytical power we're filtering
we're sorting and we're putting
everything together to answer the
question so this was the whole practice
about filtering and sorting Pokemons
um very interesting one again if you
have a chance to try to solve it by
yourself or there are a few more
projects related to filtering and
sorting all yours let's keep solving
more projects
in this project we're going to be
working with a pretty interesting
problem which is the birthday paradox
um the birthday Paradox comes actually
from the birthday problem which is a
more General problem that is basically
answering the question
if you put n people in a room what is
the probability that two people share a
birthday right so
um for example I have 70 people in a
room what is the probability that to any
pair of two people within that room
within that room of 70 people share a
birthday and it's there is a formula to
calculate thoughts the birthday Paradox
what it tells you is that it's basically
one is the number of people that I need
to I need to put in a room for that
probability to exceed 50 percent on the
counter-intuitive facts that only 23
people are needed
for that probability to be above 50
percent
so again recap only 23 people in a room
are needed for the probability of two of
any of those people any pair within that
room to share a birthday right so only
23 people are needed for that
probability to exceed 50 percent and
this is a pretty counterintuitive fact
to be I'm at least two weeks the first
time
I got asked this question my reasoning
was well what is the probability sorry
what is the number of people that I need
to be 100 sure that two people are gonna
share a birthday and the answer is of
course 366. there are 365 days in a year
so for me to be 100 sure probability
equals one that two people share a
birthday I need to put at least 366
that's gonna be 100 sure so when I got
asked well now what is how many people
do you need for that probability to be
uh my first reason it was like I don't
know 100 150 half or 365. you know it's
like and then when I got the answer and
I got to calculate the answer is like
obvious it's just well only 23 people
are needed for that probability to be 50
and we will actually understand why in a
second so basically this project deals
with the birthday Paradox and US
calculating the birthday problem the
probability of of
two people sharing a birthday in a in a
group of n people
um and then we're gonna apply that to
NBA teams and this is going to be a
pretty interesting thing because the
teams we have here we can actually run
this thing
um we can do DF at Team dot value counts
we're going to have teams that have 27
players but then we have 24 22 so we're
gonna see how many like if this
probability stands you know if we're
gonna have here the probability of
two people here at birthday in a team of
24 people the probability is going to be
greater than 50 are we gonna find
matches here or here or here Etc right
so that's going to be the problem we're
going to deal with but before we jump to
the data we're going to start with uh
the calculating the probability and
understanding
the intuition
behind this thing
the way we calculate this probability
and again is this formula is what is the
probability
of two people sharing a birthday in a
group of n people so we swap n here we
say we put 10 people in a room 20 people
in a room 50 people in our room and we
get a probability back
of uh two of them at least two of them
sharing a birthday
and the interesting part of this formula
is right here is the combinations piece
and this is when this this number only
23 is needed to get 50 percent
it starts to make sense once you take a
look at this combination uh formula here
and combinations
just a week a quick recap is if you have
um a b c d e people RAV John Mary Susan
Violet Etc the way you can combine them
is basically a with B A with C A with d
a with e
um B with c b with d b with e c with d c
with E and finally D with e these are
all the combinations you get so
pretty quickly if you start thinking in
pairs of people this number grows pretty
quickly if I put just one more person
here let's say one more person joins a
room I start adding I will add five more
combinations because it's f with a b c d
n and E so it's gonna be
um it's gonna be a an F now B and f c
on F and dnf and enf so one more person
uh what do they do wrong here one more
person that I added to the room and this
number of combination Grows by the
previous amount of people in the room
right I add one more person G and I'm
gonna do g f e d c b a right it's gonna
grow by six I added one more personal
drug bro by seven it keeps growing it
keeps growing it keeps growing so that's
why I at least to me that was what made
this problem click and understand that
is a very small number of people that we
need only 23 for the probability to
exceed 50 percent
um we can actually calculate the
combinations piece so so let's get rid
of this and buy
F so f is no longer invited to our party
so we have a b c d and we can calculate
the result of combinations of n taken by
two and this is a pretty pretty simple
and in Formula it's n factorial divided
by K factorial times n minus k n and K
in this case is n people or n taken by K
in our K is going to be n taken by two
but we can very quickly
um hack this formula it's going to be
def we call it NCR R of n taken by K and
the way it works is you can just do math
dot factorial of n divided and if you
let me I'm going to do something just
here shortcuts
this is the the beauty of python again
just assign a variable to a function
um factorial of n divided factorial of K
times factorial of n minus K and I will
return this whole thing and we have that
the combinations of five people NCR
of
five people taken by two is ten and we
said if we had a a sixth person this
thing is gonna grow by five right so it
should grow by five and up half now six
people fifteen oh is that if we add
another person right here this thing is
gonna grow by all these previous ones so
it's gonna be by six more so we're gonna
do if we have seven people this should
grow by six should be twenty one there
you go so we're calculating this thing
on the Fly that's the way it works so
now let's get to the activities and this
in this case the
the project is asking us to calculate
the probability right when n is uh
equals to ten and we can actually take a
look at there's a table here we can kind
of cheat that is the the value but we
can calculate it ourselves and to do so
what I'm gonna do is something like uh
we have one minus
uh 364 divided by 365 and here we're
going to do we're going to use our
formula or sorry our function we
calculated before that is equals to 10
people taken by 2. so n taken by 2 in
this case n is going to be 10. it's
going to 10 taken by 2 and we're gonna
use parenthesis here just in case
on our
um probability is
0.11614 in the table was 0.7 I don't
know how they computed it what rounding
they did but it's pretty much the same
value let's see if this is okay
it is okay
um
it's asked us for now equals to 15 but
I'm going to go ahead and it's it's
asking us to implement the function so
given number of people calculate the
functions we can do it generically and
the way I'm going to do it it's just
gonna do
return this thing and I have to swap
just one parameter that is here number
of people
there we go and now we're gonna do
birthday probability of 15
0.25 and put here 25 0.25
and it worked as expected and we can
check now the
um
birthday probability function all at
once
and it worked as well so we're good to
go
um so again this was quick recap that it
is for this project not to be extremely
mathy but it was just a quick recap of
birthday problem and now we're gonna
apply that to our data set to see how
many people within a team share a
birthday if any right it's going to be a
pretty interesting one so the first
thing that we're asked to do I'm gonna
delete this thing solution
um is
we need to
extract let me show you again the
a data frame we're going to extract the
birth they birth they from the birth
date function so date is the actual date
um day month year we want to extract
only the birthday right so for two
people to share a birthday they just
need to be month day it's like hey I my
birthday is September 29th yours is
September 29th we share a birthday but
potential is going to be different years
that doesn't matter so we need to
extract here the month and the day from
this data frame to do so we can use the
uh s t r f time function string format
time function this is actually part of
python in this case is implemented for a
tuple and it's implemented
let me
show you this here it's implemented in
the column birthday with a DT special
accessor don't worry too much about it
the only thing we have to do just go
ahead and Google the syntax to get this
thing to get these formats um as
expected the way it works is this
function is going to receive a
formatting so for example we can get the
year and the day right there we're gonna
get they and year and here we can put
whatever we want we can put announce
anat sign and hello
hello worlds and it's just gonna be a
formatting it's gonna format this string
that's going to replace with special
values starting with the percentage
symbols and the question now is
how can we
um get only month and and day this is
what it's asking us for birthday we can
actually go ahead and ask our assistant
so we can say
uh how can we format
the column birth dates
in the formats uh month
day do we have month day without
space and let's just go ahead and ask
the question I'm gonna press the size
here
there you go and we get pretty much
these formats
um pretty interesting uh because it's
actually the the correct answer
um
and let's try it out I'm gonna copy this
thing we're gonna
there we go
and this is the correct format so you
can see if you want you can Google we
can say
um
strf time
to pan this we're gonna find this method
we can here find python string format
documentation and here you can validate
that percentage T is going to give you
the day with leading zeros which I can't
find but but trust me there you go day
of the month
zero padded and then we're going to use
percentage month which is zero patented
month and then you can get year you can
get year with the four digits
um you can get uh day of the week you
can get Am Pm four times again you can
do any formatting you want in this case
we only need
the
um month and day so this is the format
that we are looking for
close this one and now we're gonna
assign this value
here and we're gonna check
to see if it works there you go it
worked
now
we know already what we wanna
answer is how many or which players or
how many players within a given team
this is important share a birthday so we
need to separate all the players within
a team and we need to find the ones that
um share the given birthday we could
potentially think about this problem in
different resolutions for example
finding duplicates within a team doing
Group by operations but those are all
at least given the the project we're
solving now things are a little bit more
advanced and basically what I want to
communicate with this particular project
is that sometimes we can find clever
answers clever solutions that will
pretty much give us the same results and
the one we're gonna do here is we're
gonna use combinations combinatorics to
pretty much solve the same problem
and here we have an example
we have the built-in combinations uh
formula and we have something built in
we didn't have to actually write the one
we did before but just for the sake of
the example we did it and here the way
to think about it forget for a second
about the NBA players the way to find
these people matching
is first we're going to use this
combination function but it does it puts
it aligns combinations within a given
collection so the same thing we did here
with our people so combinations right
here
this thing so remove f and g there you
go
it's going to put a with B A with C A
with d a with e b would C Etc it's doing
the same thing here John with Mary John
with Rob married Rob we can add someone
else we can add Susan we can add violet
and we're gonna and then we're gonna do
as again John Mary Rob Susan Violet Mary
Ross's and violet Rob Susan Violet Susan
Violet those are all the combinations
and then we have all the birthdays so
they let's add two birthdays let's add
on July
20th and let's add
um
September
uh 20th so we have another repetition
there we go it's gonna do March 5th
September March it's gonna do the
combinations again
and then what we can do is we can put
together these things with a little bit
of pandas we can create
these separate data frames aligning
these people and aligning these
birthdays and then combining them all
together with this simple operation
oh and I just realized that I have
overwritten our original data frame that
doesn't matter how to rate it rearrate
it
um and now we have all these
combinations of people their birthday
and now we can just ask which ones of
these people are matching and we have
that one and six are matching so one is
John and Rob because they are March 5th
both of them and six is Marion Violet
because they're both September 20th
right and we can apply the same
reasoning the same solution for our NBA
data here what we're doing is we're not
doing any Group by operations we're not
doing any algorithmic
nested for Loops that could potentially
work what we're doing is we're being
very smart and using combinations to
reshape our data
we're going from let me
do a little bit of a drawing here if you
allow me
we're gonna do we go from a small data
frame with uh one two three four five
people were reshaping it we're creating
these long formats with all the
different combinations and now we don't
need to algorithmically like iterate
this thing over and over and over again
you can just answer data by finding
chunks here how many which
combinations here are true in this case
it's uh one no I'm not good drawing one
and six what I'm saying again and we're
gonna move forward in just one second is
sometimes you need to work smart you
need to understand your data reshape it
be creative in the way you work with
your data to resolve the problem and
there's going to be a lot more scalable
than think it
algorithmically because trust me when
you start working with big pieces of
data these Solutions are more
declarative are going to be more
scalable than algorithmically we cannot
paralyze an algorithm we could
potentially break this thing imagine
you're working with millions of Records
you can put this thing into different
servers and check it in parallel that
could be completely possible but anyway
I'm I'm getting ahead of myself
and we're gonna work now by solving the
activities that we are asked in this
particular project so as I told you I am
stepping over this data frame I'm gonna
reiterate it again where is our data
frame right here and we're gonna
recreate our birth date
um column there you go we're gonna go
straight to the activities
How many pairs of players share a
birthday for the Atlanta Hawks
and again we want to use the same
solution as before to do so the first
thing we have to do is to
um
only get the players from the Atlanta
Hawks because we don't want to compare
every player with every player that's
going to be like a huge number right so
we want to get uh we actually have
um the number of players in the Atlanta
Hawks gonna be let's put in a
in a variable it's going to be
df.log DFA team equals and let me copy
directly from here
foreign
that we have teams DF dot shape we have
22 players so now what we want to do is
pretty much the same thing we did before
um I'm gonna do I'm going to copy this
thing I'm gonna paste right here I'm
gonna do instead of combinations of
names with a variable we defined what I
can do is just do team DFS
at
um
tmdf at player here I'm going to put
player one and player
two there we go
and I have the correct results one
interesting comment here
completely on the side
um we were qaing this project with
someone that resolves projects and make
sure that the quality is good there are
no errors and this person was finding an
error and saying I have too many I have
too many names right
um and I don't know what's going on and
it was a very imperative like problem
that the person was using DF instead of
Team DF
and said like have is this possible I
have 150
000 rows and this is an interesting
piece because it's like you have to kind
of understand the big range of data
you're working with like we were we were
working with Atlanta Hawks and we needed
to create these combinations of players
and we need to we have 22 people in the
thunderhawks how many combinations of
pairs you can create and this is
it's important to unders to have a range
a quick ballpark estimation of what data
you're working with and what should be
the result because I honestly don't know
if it's 231 but I do know that 100
000 is too much it's definitely too much
way too much so this hints is like
understanding the data you're working
with is kind of quickly gives you an
understanding that there is a mistake in
something you did right so if you forgot
you were filtering by the Atlanta Hawks
and you wanted to create pairs of only
these 22 players and instead you created
combinations of
551 players that number grew by a lot we
actually have our formula NCR of 551
taken by two
is the same number 151
525 and and CR of 22 players 22 players
Nintendo Hawks give us
231 rows so this makes a little bit more
sense so anyway just a comment on the
side that meant is like again have an
understanding the data we're working
with so let's go back rerun this thing
uh the names TF and we have the 231 rows
and we're going to do the same thing for
the birthday
birthday and
I do birthday here and this is gonna be
birthday
and here we're gonna do name it birthday
one um birthday
two
and finally we're gonna put by the way
they are lying 231 to 131 we're gonna
combine them with the same concat
operation we did before I don't want to
overstep the name so I'm gonna do check
DF
and their names and birthday
and now let's take a look at our data
frame we have the combination of the
player and the birthday of each one of
the players
and now we can ask the question how many
pairs of players share a birthday for
the Atlanta Hawks I'm going to do is uh
birthday one
is equals to birthday two and we're
gonna sum this whole thing seems like
there are two players
and then what we're gonna do is
DF
Dot Lock
this thing
uh no check there
there you go we have these two players
so
um Team DF let's see if all the
variables are correct because I might
have done something wrong here quick
recheck team DF is
that
we have
birthday
check the f
and we have uh two players
uh these are it two pairs
let's go ahead and try the answer
I have two players there
wrong answer try it again
um let's go ahead and recheck our thing
I don't wanna I wanna make sure I use
the rock team
and then we have uh the player and
the oh
this is a very unlucky mistake
is a very unlucky mistake for sure
when I'm checking right here
is
birthday
and using birthdays and check the dates
that we have in this particular point
this is just bad naming on my side
I used the the old data frame that I use
for the sample and the dates are in
these four months that is September 20th
whatever and I just recreated this thing
for the entire
um data frame so my mistake let's go
ahead and delete birthday DF
and delete it and we're going to use
this variable name now
and try to recheck it
and seems that we have three now
and effectively we do have three people
let's try it out now and see if it works
now it works so again the previous
mistake was just using bad variable
names I should have used something like
testing or combin tarek's birthday or
proof whatever instead of the real
variable names
but we have just fix it
How many pairs of players are birthday
in the Cleveland Cavaliers so this is
pretty much the same thing we did before
we're gonna
get up
change the date we have 22 people it's
going to be the same probability as in
that now we're gonna do
stop now
and we have only one pair
of players that share a birthday and
that's gonna be June 26th so we're gonna
just one pair
and that worked
and finally we got asked in the Dallas
Dallas Mavericks who shares a birthday
with JJ Berea they're gonna do is Rerun
our code
we have 24 players what is the
probability here and CR of 24
uh NCR 24 taken by two and we have 276
276 combinations no we actually want to
do the birthday problem
uh
there we have a 0.53 probability of two
people sharing a birthday let's actually
go ahead and do it
and we have one
um share birthday and it is JJ Berea and
Deron Williams on June 26 again
and that is the final result
so anyway a few things we saw here I
think it's pretty interesting the the
way we have solved the project without
using any algorithmic imperative and
nested for Loop Solutions we used a
data-driven approach thinking about how
we can expand this data kind of um uh
map reduce sort of solution
that I think scales pretty well and also
I made a few mistakes that I think were
um interesting to see live
um and the facts that were combining
these conceptual things resolving this
conceptual challenges mixing it with
real data and we validated that this
birthday Paradox you know we have two or
three themes teams sorry we found it for
at least three teams right here
um Atlanta Hawks Cleveland Cavaliers and
Dallas Mavericks that there were pairs
of people per players sharing a birthday
so that that is pretty interesting to
see something that is statistically
proven or the probability is is is is
high enough now we see how the
resolution in the real data in the world
in the real world data also applies so
anyway try to take a look at the project
by yourself and try to resolve it by
yourself
um and let's keep exploring more
problems together
for this project we're going to be
combining our data cleaning abilities
with our string handling abilities and
these two skills together are extremely
powerful when it comes to the process of
handling data that is coming from The
Real World so so far we've done a few
projects that had a data was pretty much
perfect we didn't have to do much
handling munching of it but that is not
the real world usually when you are
collecting data from different sources
you are pulling it from different apis
databases or it's even human generated
we're going to be dealing with a lot of
strings and as those are going to be
different sources and humans make
mistakes we are going to have
differences between these these data
points and when strings are involved and
humans are involved and multiple sources
are involved the result is pretty much
problem we will always face a little bit
of an issue in terms of the data we're
working with so it's very important to
have these sharp skills of data cleaning
and strain handling that's what we're
going to be practicing for this
particular project
let me tell you what we're going to be
working with we have two data sets that
they're explaining here but I'm gonna
just go ahead and show you the the first
few roads of both them here
they go and what you're gonna find is
that these two data frames or these data
sets they come from different sources
but they have pretty much the same
information that is company names
um what
changes is that the way this company
names was inserted input is different so
the company is by themselves like the
strings by themselves are going to have
differences but the companies are going
to be the same so in this case we have
for example from the First Data frame
um this company is pretty much the same
thing as this company but here has it
has a full name and here has just you
know a shorthand so it's like saying
apple apple is not the real name the
real name is Apple Inc dot right that's
the real string as a human it's pretty
easy for me to understand that this
company refers to this same company
right it's just pretty basic
but the question is now how can we make
that programmatic how can we build this
sort of artificial intelligence to find
the companies that are matching so we
can match the strengths and of course
continue with our analysis from this two
data sources are coming from different
sources
the answer is no artificial intelligence
yet we're gonna use a pretty simple
heuristic uh this
um deterministic method which is the 11
stain distance
um it's a simple formula that basically
will give you a number based on how
different two strings are and the good
news is that this distance is calculated
this formula is already implemented for
us in a package that is already
installed in our lab that is called the
fonts and the files has a couple of very
simple methods we can take a look right
here
ratio and partial ratio that will give
you kind of a a similarity or a distance
if you want between the two
um the two strings and new parts in this
case I think it's easier to think about
in terms of similarity right so these
two strings are pretty similar the only
thing that changes uh is an exclamation
mark so the seminar is pretty high 97.
so
um we're going to be using this library
to compute this distance so let's move
forward with uh the first couple of
activities and the first thing that we
have to understand is how are we gonna
match this uh companies we could do
something like a for Loop nested right
so let's say we have uh two companies so
A and B three companies and c and we
have
um a a Inc
and B and brothers
and C
and how can we match of course we have
more than those we could actually take a
look we have shape of df1 we have 266
for the first one and 368 for the second
one
but the way we could do it is with kind
of a nested for Loop we could do
something like four uh C1 in companies
one and four C2 in companies 2 right and
we can do uh something like distance
let's let's similarly is equals to let's
just use some quick
um quick pseudocode here of C1 and C2 if
same is greater 90
um and we can store these things let's
let's make we're gonna make something
like companies similar companies
we're gonna do
uh similar companies dot append we're
going to put C1 and C2
but this algorithmic approach
doesn't let us visualize the datum and
see and do a little bit of an analysis
of what how the data changed how the
data is represented under the hood we're
gonna just do this hard Cuts in 90
without the ability to see if maybe
there was an 89 that was fairly good and
don't don't don't worry about the number
itself because I mean 90 89.85
this approach algorithmic imperative
approach is not extremely it's not very
Analytical in in from some point of view
it's not easy to see why or how things
are working behind the scenes so an
alternative way that we're proposing for
this particular projects is to create
combinations of the columns and pretty
much do these same process
match every company with every company a
with a Inc B and pros and C B with a Inc
B and Bros and C C with a Inc BM pros
and zinc match every company with every
company
and to do that there is a very simple
method which is The Ether tools dot
product method so we have imported the
either tools method and we're gonna do
here let me remove this thing and we're
gonna do companies one and companies
to these are plurals I'm going to do
ether tools
heater tools dot products of C1 cs1 and
CS2 and we need to wrap this thing in a
list to visualize it there we go and we
have pretty much the combinations of
everything with everything which is
again what we were uh wanted to do so
now what we can do is we can just pretty
much do four let's say we use an
imperative approach again we're going to
do four C1 C2 in this thing
right and now we can say pretty much the
same thing we're saying doing before we
can compute the similarity
of these two companies
but the result is we went from a nested
computational intensive for look to
something that is a declarative
expressive data-driven approach in this
case we're generating the data and now
we can do some different things if we
think about this thing in a data frame
we could potentially add a third column
that is the similarity so now we're
going to have a a Inc and the similarity
column and now we can start doing some
analysis we can filter all the values
that have greater similarity we can do a
uh we can do some plotting for some of
the confidence have some certain
similarity we can visualize we can
explore we can analyze the data in a
more declarative analytical way than
just doing a simple not simple but just
a more rudimentary naive iteration or
imperative algorithm so let's move
forward let's get rid of all these
things and we we're gonna start
approaching the first activity which is
basically asking us to build that data
frame build this data frame that
contains the companies of uh sorry the
contains all the companies from csv1 and
the product of csv2 and also compute the
ratio for all of them right so we have
to put these two things together the
first thing we're gonna do
um is we are going to
do DF at we're not asked for the ratio
right here this screenshot is incorrect
we're just gonna compute we're gonna
just compute the product and create the
large csb so um what we're going to be
doing here is we're going to do DF one
add client uh clients the values that's
going to be our first list so remember
we have either tools.products here's a
syntax collection one collection two so
we're gonna pass for collection one
we're gonna pass the row for for df1 and
for collection two
the F2 we're gonna pass then it's firm
name
dot values
we can pass this whole thing to a data
frame
pde.data frame
this whole thing gonna break it into
a different row and we can say column
names columns it's gonna be CSV one and
CSV two
and I have a non-matching parenthesis
because I need to close that one
and we have an error with columns no
firm name values name there we go
sorry we have a few mistakes this is
pretty much the the regular process of
data analysis of data processing
and now what we see is we have created
this huge let's actually take a look the
F shape
um this huge data frame with the same
expected rows as the one we have right
here 97
000 rows which is going to be the result
of the product of the F1 shade and the
F2 shape
um so let's give it a try and see if it
passes
there you go it worked so so far so good
we have our product of different company
names so we can do a little bit of
matching
um now
we are gonna apply the rage the
Levenstein distance right to compute the
similarly between the company so of
course the similarity between these two
is going to be uh a lot the similarity
between these two is going to be 100 I
mean sorry the similarity here is going
to be pretty low the distance is going
to be pretty uh High the cylinder is
going to be pretty low the similarly in
these two companies Adobe for both of
them it's gonna be pretty good so um
we're gonna be using this library for uh
fuzz dot partial ratio partial ratio
because the companies have white spaces
so it's gonna pretty much compute the
the words in different orders and this
might be helpful
um all right so
what we're gonna do here is we're gonna
compute the ratio score and we're going
to swap to the activity first so this is
the second activity that is asking us to
compute the ratio score we have right
there
we have
the ratio score here of these two
companies and how can we do that
well it's pretty simple as we already
have the values so we have the F uh we
can just do values here
values and we can do something like
um let's say score
equals uh fuzz dots partial ratio of C1
and C2 for C1 C2 in DF dot values
it's going to take a little bit of a
moment there you go we can get like the
first 10 scores
and we can now basically apply thoughts
to ratio score and take a look at the
different ratios and now we have that
adobe systems right obviously has a 100
similarity while something like Adobe
with Advanced Micro Devices Inc has a
lower similarity right the only thing
similar is probably the ink and the
individual individual characters
all right so so far so good the first
part of these process is understanding
how we created a declarative descriptive
approach by Transforming Our data and
working with a different Foundation it's
like we move the floors like we started
with these two different data frames and
now we have just a single one that has
these very useful column with the
combined ratio of the similarities of
each of each company so now let's move
forward with a few more activities and
this is pretty much the whole data
analysis process I'm gonna create a
division here and we can get started
um how many rows have a ratio a score of
90 of more and there's going to be
df.log DF at ratio score greater or
equals to 90. and let's take a look at
that
I made a mistake
there we go
and we can now
check how many
we have and we have a hundred and six
companies
there you go
what is a corresponding company in csv2
to a e-com in csv1 and this is the one
that we pretty much saw here at the
beginning this one right here but let's
go ahead and give it a try
um there we go so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna find I'm gonna do uh df.log
or let's actually use Query so we change
things eight bits I'm gonna do CSV one
is equals to this one
and
ratio score is equals to Watts or
greater than what I'm gonna say let's
say 80 to take a look
there you go so these two have a 100
ratio score because again we're using a
partial ratio if we were using a
ratio only ratio this is going to be
lower
actually 30.
um and that's because there is in
reality there is a lot of dispersion or
distance between these two words there
is no much similarity like again to the
human eye there's a lot of similarity
here because we can zoom in and just
focus in these two words but if you
think about it's like this whole thing
makes the second string completely
different and that's why we use the
partial ratio partial ratio which now
gives you a 100 score because it's doing
the same thing we do with our eyes which
is basically focusing attention in
different words right and give you the
combination of individual works so
anyway uh let's try it out this should
work as expected
um and basically here's like we are
um we are basically trying to understand
what's going to be the kind of value
that is gonna make us right this side if
a company programmatically speaking
right in an in an automated way if a
company name matches another company
name say where is the cutoff in value
um so CSV one company the fifth activity
is Starbucks
what's the corresponding company in csv2
we're gonna do the same thing and let's
keep the ratio equals 80.
and we have that it's Starbucks
Starbucks Corporation
and let's enter it right here it works
but again the ratio score was 100 100 so
by doing some analysis we can start
understanding how this um this different
um ratios are going to be distributed
something that I'm gonna do in at the
end just as some other activities so
activity number six is there a matching
company in Pinnacle West Capital comp
Corporation so let's copy this thing
once again
and put that and there aren't like
definitely these two are not related but
what we see right here just because I
randomly chose uh choose I'm randomly
choosing to use 80.
as as the racist score to do the cutoff
it's like there are two companies that
have nothing to do with Pinnacle West
Capital Corporation but they have a
ratio score of 83 and the answer is that
because they have they have the
corporation word
so we have to be very careful so I'm
going to say here no let's see what's
the answer that worked
um and let's move forward seven activity
how many matching companies are there
for County of LA blah blah blah
and now we're gonna put this thing and
we're gonna keep the ratio equals 80. so
we can take a look and keep
understanding what we have
um so there's a very clear difference
here
we have
um two companies that have a value of 82
and two companies that have one 100 195
so both 90. so I'll be tempted to say
two here there are two companies that's
match the name for County of Los Angeles
blah blah blah
um we should take a look at the full
names so we can do that
um with
pde.options options maybe I can ask our
AI assistants if I don't remember this
display
Max marks
marks on
there you go that was one
um if you ever have the dub you can just
ask the systems go for it don't worry in
Googling or asking the AI assistant
because that's pretty useful
um and here now we can we can take a
look at them and we say
County of Los Angeles the first
Compensation Program County of Los
Angeles
defer Compensation Program and then we
have city of Los Angeles so I'll
potentially say
how many companies seem to be in CSV and
we're gonna say two
there we go they seem to be the same
company or they are not companies
entities to put it away
so finally a activity is there a
matching company for the Queens Health
Systems what we can do here is run
pretty much the same operation
and we find the Queen's Health System
just with the apostrophe and the S so is
there a matching we're gonna say yes
and by doing this analysis and we have
a thing we're missing one activity
I think I have completed oh let's check
this activity
there you go we have no more activities
to complete all the project passed but
by performing this analysis so first we
did a little bit of data wrangling we
did a little bit of uh managing to get
to the ratio score and now we're kind of
close to start generating
the the final CSV if you want the final
representation of what would be the
matching companies and here we don't
have an activity in this particular one
on purpose because there is still a data
cleaning process that it's kind of
annoying it could take a little bit of
time but we can start taking a look at
we're gonna say for example df.log DF at
ratio score greater than 90 right and we
can take a look at how many companies
are matching that
um the uh that query we can go one step
further and when you're doing data
cleaning something very useful to do at
least to me is to start visualizing your
data so I'm going to do ratio's core and
here I'm going to plot kind kind hist
ASE thoughts if a ratio
surpasses 19
most of the samples are going to be
between 98 9 and 100. so it'll be
interesting to see what companies we
have here
let's actually
um we get we can actually take a look
also at a box plot so we're going to do
box
and we have pretty much the same results
like everything is concentrated in 100
and it'll have a few samples in 96 95 93
so let's actually take a look at those
we're going to say the F dot query let's
do query now where ratio ratio score is
greater than 90. and
is less than
97 let's say
and now we can take a look at what's
going on in here
and this is again this is the data
analysis process so in this case we have
one that seems to be very compelling
this one is pretty much the same thing
Idaho Power Co is lit it's the same as
Idaho Idaho Power Company Jack in the
Box Ing and Jack in the Box in with 95
let's actually sort my let's sort
values by ratio score and we're going to
start with the ones are like less like
or more likely so the Queen's Health
System pretty much the same thing Jack
in the Box pretty much the same thing
colony of Los Angeles and Seattle
whatever whatever we did before
Sacramento city Sacramento County of
course we have to understand if the city
and the county for us are represent the
same entity or not but nevertheless
Idaho Power Company is the same Safeway
Inc is the same
these two are probably the same but now
we're getting into a little bit of even
with this one we're getting into
terrain that it's a little bit less
clear what's going on here so I'm not so
sure and this is because I don't know
the business we're running if these
um company or institution is the same as
this one right here potentially right
but this is where you have to start to
ask so
um in this case we have Contra Costa
County and Sonoma County and these are
this is different again I don't know the
business but I'll bet that these two
companies are not the same the same
thing with again Contra Costa and Marin
County so I bet that these two are
definitely not the same while there is a
little bit of a mixed ground between
let's say this one and these two in
terms of if city and county in city and
county are the same institutions and
then there is no doubt in the last two
so basically this illustrates the real
process of data cleaning
which is
first of all if we would have done this
process before it was a nested for look
that I deleted remember nested for Loop
for company one in companies one
for company to in company and when do we
do it manually it's very hard to
visualize this
um sort of relationships so what we did
right here was by first reshaping our
data and having a clear picture of all
the data we had we were able to create a
more descriptive representation we
calculated this ratio Score company we
started doing some analysis we answered
some basic questions like can we find a
company here there can we find this kind
of value we know I just chose 80 but we
could have used 75 and see how how it
went and then
um we took a look at at the distribution
of the ones that seem to be more likely
and we found like these middle grounds
it was something like we probably need
to go back to whoever is running the
business or you know just Google it and
start understanding the data that we're
dealing with because data cleaning at
the end of the day might be you you do
need a ton of domain knowledge I can't
just claim data with my data cleaning
techniques without understanding data
that I'm cleaning I might be a great
data scientist but if I'm
cleaning biological
data or data from a physics lab I will
have no idea what data I'm working with
right so that's a very very common
common uh case you have you know you're
working with a high tech
and you have measurements from
instruments and you have something like
I don't know a column T you have a value
that is
0.0091 and it's like is this fine or not
and maybe the physic the physics guy
comes and says hey this is completely
wrong you're missing the columns this
the T value should be in the orders of
hundreds not in the orders of I don't
know very small right so I need to
understand the data but to understand
the data to understand the domain to be
able to ask questions to be able to
Google things to be able to go to The
Archives of the company I need to put
that in a good representation that
allows me to do that and that's what
we're doing with this representations we
have created so anyway I have talked a
lot so far in these projects because for
data cleaning this is the most important
thing is being able to reproduce your
experiments visualize and understand
what's going on
um take a look at the project try to
resolve by yourself or keep working with
other custom projects we have for data
cleaning is that it's a very fun
activity pretty much all the time
this project is focused on beta cleaning
and some data analysis after the data is
clean and it's a very interesting one
because the data we're using it comes
from someone that is scraped right just
scraped the HTML out of the Google's
Play Store right so as as you might know
whenever you're scraping data you should
be wary of issues in the resulting data
because I mean web pages are not
extremely structured they change a lot
so if you have a scraping job that takes
time because I mean we have a lot of
reviews here we have like 10 000 apps
that were scrape from the app store
that's gonna take time it's not you can
just hit a button and that's going to
complete in just a second it will it
might actually complete in a matter of
weeks because Google bans your IP the
one that it's scraping of course this is
I think this is even illegal right but
somehow done it and again it's going to
take time to scrape and time equals that
things might change you might duplicate
you might create the same app two times
so results might not be ideal to put in
a way
so the way we are gonna we're gonna
go with this is first understanding the
data we're dealing with so that's pretty
much the first step we're gonna do
df.info and we're gonna kind of brace
for impact here it's like we know that
there might be things going on wrong so
the first thing is we have ten thousand
eight hundred forty one entries the
total in number in the index and then we
quickly see that rating has far less
value so there are no there are no
values here also we see something like
for example reviews right here which
should be numeric and or rating we see
that rating is actually numeric so this
is a good thing but there are non-values
but then we see that something like
reviews in this case right here that is
not numeric it's an object it's a string
so what's going on in here that's the
question we're asking ourselves
so um let's actually get started with
activities and it says which of the
column following column or columns have
no values we quickly saw that rating is
one of those we can use the missing
no Library this one right here missing
no just a gives you a quick
visualization and as usual I like to
start my analysis with a quick
visualization when I'm working with with
something trying to understand the data
a quick uh histogram box plot one of
these missing values visualization is
recommended the second stage is doing an
analytical review of what's going on
Etc so let's do a right here missing no
we have import we have already installed
the app for you or the library and it's
already imported here at Smo we're going
to do a bar Matrix is the most common
one
um like this one I'm gonna do a bar and
we're going to do the whole data frame
it's going to show us that very quickly
the rating right has a good chunk of
missing values right there
what else well there are fuel here but
it's hard to see with the bar and one
here
840 one missing value here and this is
this is hard to read because the bars
don't help so now we can switch to
something analytical and of course we
kind of saw that because we have 10 40
uh 10 sorry 840 840 833 which we know
that the full index has 10 841
um but to do so with an analytical way
we can just do is an a we can do no sum
and that's going to give us
there you go really quickly the apps
that have the columns that have no
values and we can sort this doing sort
values ascending
false
there you go so we have here we can
start answering rating of course
both versions type and content writing
type and content rating
there you go both are now
um
claim there you go are no values in all
of them so now second second activity
and this is again as usual I encourage
you to pause right now try to solve by
yourself because it's an interesting one
so three part activity remove the
invalid values from rating if any just
set them as nans okay invalid values and
let's take a look at rating we're gonna
do now again as usual we can start with
a quick visualization uh at rating dot
plots a kind
histogram real quick
and it doesn't look so so might be okay
but we already see that there are some
that are above five which is of course
not a valid rating and this is my usual
comment that you have to understand the
data you have to understand the domain
you're working with to do correct data
science because we know that the rating
of an app goes from like zero to five or
actually from one to five so if you have
anything above five or below one they'll
be valid right and it's it's a number so
the the the column is okay in terms of
the type first check that for example we
saw already that reviews wasn't so
reviews is an object this is already
here reviews this it seems to be numeric
but then we check the analytical version
with info we quickly see that it's not
parse is a number so now it's raising
suspicious we're gonna take a look at
that later
but here in rating we understand our
data and we know
thoughts the top the the maximum number
the rating can be is five and this goes
above five so that's clearly invalid
let's turn this thing into a box plot
uh we're going to we're going to do vert
Falls
and now we can clearly see that there
are a bunch of samples that are
completely invalid let's take it now to
the analytical version we're going to do
rating we're gonna do this drive
there we go and we have
maximum value which is uh 19 definitely
invalid all right let's check it out to
say tf.log the effort rating
uh greater than five and there are a
bunch of UPS here and we're gonna need
to claim these ups and the rules set
them as Nan that is it so here
um we're gonna do this amps at rating
we're going to do equals to np.nan
that's it
but then it says fill the null violation
rating so the ones we have just done and
the other one because there were like a
thousand apps without a rating using the
mean so basically what we're gonna do
here is we're gonna do DF at rating
rating
uh dot mean we're going to use this
volume
I want to say DF at rating dot fill
okay keep that rating dot fill n a
with this value in place
equals true
and now
it's pretty much the same thing
um
and now it says we can't check that yeah
it's because it says clean any other non
non-numerical columns but just dropping
the values and this is understandable
because we we don't have so many so we
have 10 000 apps in total like ten
thousand eight hundred forty one ups but
there are apps like occurrences rows
symbols but there are only a painful
like 13 13 apps that have either a
missing version a missing type A content
writing so it's not that bad we're gonna
have so many missing apps so we can just
get rid of them that's basically what
this this activity is saying so we're
going to say DF dot drop n a in place
sure that's it
and that works
All Right Moving On To The Next One
reviews we already talked about reviews
we saw that it's that it was parsed let
me take this right here it was parsed as
an object pandas is going to try to
parse any column as a as a number okay
this is by definition it's going to try
to parse the column as a number if it
can't because the column is not a number
they're string they're final characters
it will just default back to object and
that's exactly what happened here but
again the question is like we take a
look the F adds ratings no reviews dot
head and they look numbers that's
numbers but it's an object so let's
check it out and see what happened we
could actually double check doing a two
numeric
to numeric and we know this is gonna
fail because somehow I mean pandas was
not able to part his number so there is
no way this is going to work it didn't
because basically there are values here
that are invalid so somewhere in this
list of 10 000 apps there will be
um values that are not fully numeric and
let's explore for that a good way to
explore for that
is I have my AI assistant here that I
asked earlier for example what is the
syntax of pd2 numeric when I was
checking this this project to resolve
and it's telling me that there is this
method which is I can pass an optional
attribute which is errors equals course
right here and that's gonna instead of
raising errors with a you know loud red
message it's gonna turn the no values as
the evaluate balances Nan's so basically
that means
we can do that I can create a new column
reviews numeric
that is a result of that
and now I can say df.lock
show me the rows in which this row that
I have this column that I have just
created is Nan because that means that
wherever there is a non-value no value
missing value in this new column that is
because there was a number there that
wasn't that pandas couldn't parse and
when it couldn't parse it it just
assigned Nan
and
that is basically
what is happening right here reviews
numeric is
n-a-n-n-a-n-n-a-n and we can take a look
at the actual reviews and we see that
there is this m Valley here symbolizing
for Millions to two million one million
six four five million we wanna turn this
thing into numbers
to do so what we can do is DF odds let's
say
df.lock DF at reviews
dots
um I could have just done the f.log
at 72 no here we can do I'm not gonna do
it but I can just do 178
1781 and I can just do two million
one million ad reviews of course here
reviews but of course it's not very
scalable
um so I'm gonna do something else which
is just making automatic to put it away
automated like it's going to be
completely generic and this is what
we're looking for so basically find me
all the reviews that contain
contains an m
right so these are the invalid values
um what are the reviews now
there you go
and now what we can do is dot Str dot
replace we can do M with nothing so it's
going to remove the and I'm doing this
step by step by the way I could have
just done in just one line but I'm
showing you a step-by-step resolution
and basically we can now turn this thing
into numeric p.2 numeric
of this thing there we go but we thought
it was 2 million so we need to multiply
it back to one by one million
we have the value
but we want to assign this thing to the
reviews column which is a string type so
it's usually recommended to turn this
whole thing back as type Str so we want
to make it a string
because now we can take these values new
reviews
new reviews
and there you go I'm going to
break into a new line
break into the line
there
these new reviews
the rework
now let me put it right here new reviews
there
these reviews
basically want to assign them back again
to the which one this
no this I'm already making a mess of
myself this results so basically when I
get these things I want to assign it the
previous value right so we can do do you
want to do the whole thing let's do
everything just one line as I promised
we're gonna do that
let's see if it works
so now we can look again for this count
these apps
and let's take a look at the whole row I
guess now the reviews have been
correctly cleansed but so far this is a
string right we have knots which is we
have just fixed the three occurrences
which we could have fixed a thousand
occurrences because again this method is
pretty generic it works for pretty much
anything
um
we are gonna turn the whole thing now to
a number so we're going to do PDF at
reviews
let's check first
to numeric
there you go it worked so it didn't
raise an error that is good we now can
assign that back to reviews uncheck our
activity finally
finally and it worked okay moving
forward to the next one how many
duplicated apps are there and in this
case it's asking us for the total
duplicated apps let me do a quick recap
of the duplicated method undo duplicate
it
um
df.log
DF ads
duplicated uh subsets
up
sort sort
values by
up
at 10.
there you go we have all these apps out
here is the currents that I'm looking
for so basically here eight ball pool
um
so
what it shows by defaults if you have so
if you have for example Twitter
you have Facebook
Facebook what this method is going to
show you is only this one is duplicated
and normally
this one is duplicated
that happens because I mean this is the
real one for pandas the first occurrence
is like the real one the second one is a
duplicated one the same if you have
multiple apps so if you have six
occurrences or five whatever one two
three four five there is one good and
four are duplicated that's basically
what pandas does by default in this case
activity is asking us for the for
different Behavior saying if there are
two occurrence of Twitter that should
count as two you want to Mark like
Twitter is here is two times duplicated
to do so what we need to do is pass a
parameter which is keep
sorry I already made a mess keep
faults
and somehow
because that should go inside the
parenthesis
there we go and now it seems that it's a
little bit more interesting in this case
because we have every occurrence of the
given up
and there is also one more thing to
comment here is that let's say you have
this app
and you have the number of reviews which
is 19100 for one of them and the other
one is 19 100 there you go so these two
rows for pandas are completely
duplicated these two rows but if you
have something like I don't know ten
thousand eight nine one and eleven zero
zero zero two if you have these two rows
right there if you just do DF dot
duplicate it let's do keep
Falls
sum
by pandas by default it's going to tell
us there are 18 800 sorry 880 duplicated
rows but for this to be count as
duplicator Road the whole thing has to
be the same so in this example this
would be just two these two are
duplicated but these two here are
completely different rows to me that's
what Panda says because the values are
in are different
for us to say we want to count
duplicated apps we need to do these
subsets up right so let's do thoughts
copy this thing
now we're gonna do
there and now we can count 1979
um Ops because again there are some
roads are completely the same there are
some rows that are different at least in
some other column but the opposition
let's actually try to visualize that I
can say and
and
it's might take me a while but and it's
not this thing
here we go that works so basically these
are the apps that are duplicative
but there is something different between
these rows so for example between these
two rows there is something different
and it's here the reviews this one has
six sixes five two one it has six six
two four six so this one has more
um more
reviews on the second one and again
remember where the date is coming from
it's coming from the scraping process so
there is a chance that this app was
scraped two times at two different
points in time and of course we have a
duplicated rows with different data
anyway let's answer the activity how
many duplicated apps but counting them
whole do we have 1979 let's check if
that works and it goes it
next activity drop duplicated apps
keeping only the ones with the greatest
number of reviews and these are very
interesting one you will sort you will
need to sort data frame up and reviews
and that will change the order of the
data frame that is fine because what is
going to happen is and again you have to
understand
let me copy this thing once again but
I'm going to sort Now by up
um by
uh reviews
yeah this these lines are extremely
short
there you go
so what happens here is that
we have again this creeping process that
potentially scraped two times or more
than two times you have like two four
six seven times
um and the reasoning at least what I'm
thinking is that
the the scrapping process took like an
entire week and somehow this person
scraped the same amount multiple times
but there is one important hint at least
to me which is that the number of
reviews in an app is probably always
going up right it's like you will sell
them delete reviews that you've done in
an app I don't know if that's even
possible potentially as possible but
basically what I'm thinking here is that
and basically what the activity is
asking is that we want to do drop
duplicates and what is the freshest copy
of this creeping process what is the app
that get gets closer to the real number
today and that is potentially the one
with the greatest number of reviews the
one with the most reviews
because again the reasoning is that this
was scraped on Monday it was a screen of
Tuesday Tuesday Wednesday Wednesday
Saturday Sunday right because all these
apps have a different number of reviews
and this one the one below right at the
bottom because we sorted by reviews has
potentially the greatest it's
potentially the greatest freshest copy
of the app from the scraping process
let's say so what we have to do here is
we can sort this data frame in this way
so we can do let's keep a copy this is a
good technique
um as we're changing the data frame
we're making several modifications it's
a good practice to keep a copy in memory
just in case you can always go back to
this copy the way I do it is just copy I
can put a number like this is activity
number five DF copy five or DF copy
before removing reviews you know
something like that and I usually just
comment it out immediately because if I
execute this cell again nothing happens
I don't hurt my copy so again if we make
a mistake we can always roll back we can
do DF equals DF copy copy five
dot copy and we have back again the data
in this previous stage
but anyway let's let's keep moving
forward with activity and what we want
to do is we want to sort the values so
df.sorval is up reviews in place true
and now we're ready to do DF
dot drop duplicates drop
duplicates there you go we're ready to
do this thing but the interesting part
is that we need to say subsets
is by op
and there is a parameter in drop
duplicates which is
which is I don't know why the
documentation is not working
um what's this syntax of
uh DF to drop duplicates
let's quickly I could also do something
I don't know if you know this trick
because you help this method
right here gives you the help that
should work with the same uh this one
right here but let's wait for the
assistance print rate of this
there you go and there is this parameter
which is Kip first and what Kip first
does is
basically
we the way panda is gonna
work is it's gonna find the duplicates
right in this case eight ball pool is
the app it's gonna again one is gonna be
marked as good everything else is
duplicate but the question is which one
is marked as good
um in this case as we sorted the data
frame in this order that the one at the
bottom is the one with the with the
greatest number of reviews we want to do
a keep last we want to remove all this
and when I keep only this copy okay
that's again the syntax let me show that
to you for a sec right here keep last
that's what we want to do so
let me close this
and we're going to do drop duplicates
subsets
up
I do keep
last
I do in place
true and this is when we're changing the
data frame again and we can now check
the activity
and
it didn't work
um
it's strange and potentially could go
back again to the copy and we can try
once again
and reviews oh
potentially this activity is checking
that might be it so let's give the copy
what it is let me just try this out
DF at reuse numeric let me get rid of
this column and check the activity once
again there you go it worked my mistake
I was not supposed to create a new
column
um which I did
okay moving forward format the category
column this is an interesting one
because let's take a look at category
first
counts there you go
um category oh uppercase yes they're all
uppercase we can see that and it says
that white spaces are actually we are
using underscore for that we can check
that as well we have to change that we
have to make this thing remove the
uppercase just use white spaces and
capitalize it so autumn vehicles in this
format becomes Autumn vehicles in these
formats so we're going to do this very
quickly
another category is equals to the effort
category dot Str dot replace and we're
going to replace here the underscore
with a wide space
that's the first replacement we're gonna
do and the second one is we're gonna
capitalize
the whole thing
and now we're gonna check we can check
again this thing
and where is auto Vehicles out on
vehicles ideal it's going to be the same
let's say the kit out and it works as
expected
okay activity number seven clean and
convert the installs column to numeric
type get rid of this there we go clean
and convert installs columns in America
and the Clans
and some values don't have a plus
modifier just remove this string and
honor the original number okay
so as usual we can do something like I
don't want to create a new column so I'm
going to do df.log DF we're going to do
remember the pd.2 numeric of TF at
installs
errors
right it is an A so basically the
opposite cannot the rows that cannot be
parsed as a number well look use that
for a selection we're going to do a head
real quick
and installs 500 10 000 with a comma
separator one million the plus with the
common separator so basically what we
can do and I think I could do this whole
thing just one line would be DF at oh my
bottom my button
installs
at scr but replace I'm going to replace
the plus symbol with nothing we're gonna
remove it just chain the whole thing
chain the command and we're going to do
comma with nothing we're going to
separate thoughts and what I do pd.2
Merrick of this whole thing
there you go seems It's not failing so
that means this is working and finally
we're gonna assign this thing to
installs
um let me see if there is anything else
no that is perfectly fine
um there is no M bright because I only I
only remove the plus symbol and the
comma and that just transformed to
numeric so it seems like I'm fake I'm
safe sorry
and we're gonna assign this to installs
and check the activity and it worked
clean and convert activity number eight
there there you go let me Center its
activity activity number eight clean and
convert the size column to numeric
representing bytes size Columns of type
objects some values are either m or k so
that's basically megabytes or kilobytes
let's take a look at our data frame once
again there you go sign size this is 3.6
megabytes 9.1 megabytes
203 kilobytes we want to turn this thing
into a
um into a bytes it seems right when I
turn this thing into bytes
nine
a98 to will become this thing which is
the bytes thing that is that is good
some other rules all right remember
apply the rules as previous tasks like
the one in the plus so if we do DF
let's do df.log DF
I do
pd2 numeric
and I think this is a good time to keep
a copy the F copy h d f a copy
there you go oh my bad
reloading reloading
reloading scanning scanning scanning
scanning
uh where were we
size we didn't save the notebook DF copy
eights equals the F the copy
and we're gonna comment that out
and as usual we're going to do DF at
size
dot Str dot replace
m
with nothing and Str dot replace K with
nothing we don't want to do that right
now because we want to convert this
thing to the real numbers but for now if
I do pd2 numeric of this thing what
happens
unable to parse string
Vari vares with device so that is
because
some other values are completely invalid
there is no way to infer numeric type
from them so these are uh to replace
with zero okay so we can start right
there we can say
VF df.lock
the effort size equals
memorize with device
dot shape how many oh okay a ton so
there are a ton of these sort of apps
um and here we want to do that these
column size
for that condition should be zero so
when I do just I'm gonna do
um
zero us type
Str as usual remember that this is not
gonna work potentially
PD
this might be fine let's let me try it
out if it doesn't work we have the copy
as usual we want to keep the values the
string
um DF at size
is is still an object so that's good
um
and now it seems that it's working so
there you go it seems that it's working
DF odds tf.head
we only have to replace R there DF Dot
Lock the F at size
dot Str dot contains a comma
um Carl must know containing no I
we we made a mistake let me go back
again
copy
this is a good thing
um we're gonna
basically say PD series
zero
thoughts
and I we made a mistake again
the F copy
copy
there you go because we might not be
able to assign it so what I'm going to
do is just
more string handling which is the usual
way of doing this process
which is the effort size equals the
effort size dot Str dot replace I'm
gonna replace this whole thing
all right so it's size for a zero in
this way
there we go and there you go it worked
so the the copy is saving us
so there is nothing with a comma that is
good and it seems like we can
potentially convert if we fix the issue
with the M on Decay let's go ahead and
do it once again we did it already this
process basically what we're going to do
is the f.log let's start with the
kilobytes DF at size dot Str dot
contains the k
okay lower lowercase k
um really quickly let me check that
and what we're gonna do now is we are
gonna take these reviews
uh no size that's what we're looking for
and basically we want to convert this
thing we're gonna
convert this thing dot Str
dot uh replace
the k with nothing
right we want to
there we go we want to now turn this
thing into numeric PD Dot
two
numeric
there you go but these are kilobytes and
what the activity is asking us is for
megabytes so we're gonna do now
sorry for bytes these are kilobytes is
acting up four bytes we have to multiply
this whole thing by 20 20 10 24 and now
these are kilobytes
so basically what we are able to do now
is as usual we're gonna get this thing
those sizes and we're going to assign
them to this thing right here
this is going to be a long string
and the size of the lines is not great
there we go so what we're doing is
selecting all the rows that have a k
turning dot k
to a removing Decay turning into a
number multiplying it for 10 24 because
it's going to be bytes and at the end as
usual we want to keep that as a string
there you go
um
we're going to do the same thing now
with megabytes I'm just going to replace
m
and M
m m
and of course here is 10 24 times time
24 for megabytes
I'm gonna do that
finally PD to numeric
of the effort size
it works let me show you
the size now so this was three something
maybe we have a copy here size there's
Pier 3.6 M so that is 3.6 M this one
right here with 3.6 M so 3.6
times 10 24 times 10 24.
is pretty much the same value we have
right here so it's good but it's still
an object because we were using strings
for everything which is a good thing
keep strings keep strings keep working
with strings until you're good I'm sure
you want to convert that into a number
we can do that right now
and let's check the activity this is a
long one took a little bit of wrangling
there we go but finally we have
successfully cleaned it
all right moving forward clean and
convert the prize column to numeric
clean and convert the price column to
numeric uh the value represents
with a dollar symbol at price
um
dots different than zero
df.blog we're gonna check a few prices
um that zero is a string there you go
1.49 seems to be good let's check if
there is one that has a comma or
anything like that
contains a comma nothing so I think we
can just let's let's try it out what if
we do PD dots I mean Chris sides here
two numeric of this thing dot replace
uh dollar symbol with nothing which is
dots
oh no there are value values oh because
there is a bunch of price equals free
oh yeah
symbol that is for price
all right so we can do
um DF at price
we can actually
check
free
yeah they're a bunch that are free so DF
at Price equals the
effortprize.str that replace free with a
string representing zero and now it
seems to be working
so let's do thoughts and now let's check
the activity
worked
finally paid or free now you have
cleared the price column let's create
another one distribution to the
distribution
equals uh the conscious contain free
paid values depending on the app's price
so this is a good one we could iterates
over each prize right over the whole
data frame of price and just assign one
thing or the other
um we could use an apply function we
could do something like
um
equals we could do DF at Price dot apply
a Lambda
with a price p and puts
um
we're going to free
if p is greater than zero else
paid
and do that
and I could assign that to distribution
and say this
let me check just as we're doing it but
there is
no didn't work actually that's a good
thing
um because
oh
paid it's on the other way it's paid if
pre other ways free I just and that's
why I don't like the apply one and
potentially at this stage if you're just
still doing data cleaning you might not
know this method but there's another
simpler way that it's just hacking
pandas which is Owl initiates let's
let's actually see if this works first
um distribution or no I want to use my
method so distribution
is going to be like I say distribution
is like everything is going to be free
like let's start that way it's free we
can check the activity this is not going
to work not didn't work
but then what we're gonna say is df.lock
all the apps that have a prize that is
greater than zero right that so price
here we're gonna get the the
distribution column I want to send that
to paid that way now we can check the
activity
and that works so the way and I'm gonna
get rid of the apply for a sec the way
this method which is again the most
convenient is just if you have a few
rules what you can do is just
you know
start with the one that is going to give
you like
70 of the apps are free
and then just work your way creating
other conditions to replace the others
this is a very common technique
all right now that we have finished with
data cleaning we can just do a quick
analysis to answer all these questions
so what company has the most reviews we
can do something like DF dot sort values
by reviews
ascending Falls head by the way as usual
is a good time to stop the video try to
resolve it by yourself I will just you
know move very quickly over all these
activities because this is more analysis
that we've done I think it's still
interesting but if you can try to
resolve by yourself first and then take
a look at the solution I've done so the
first thing is the app that has the most
reviews this works also as usual
DF ad reviews
equals the F at reviews
.mox
that is Facebook
good which is a category with the most
uploaded apps and this is DF uh
categories dot value counts
family is the category it seems with the
most there you go
UPS
to which category belongs the most
expensive app so we can do DF dot sort
values as usual
um
by
price uh sending false dot head and I'm
rich Trump Edition lifestyle what's the
price for a hundred dollars for an app
okay I gotta do
TS
and it works again it's a live type
application
what's the name of the most expensive
game what's the name of the most
expensive game
um find the most expensive app in the
game category and enter its name so
basically we're gonna do the same thing
as here
but we're gonna lock
here we're gonna do we're gonna do query
where the category
is game
and the game seems to be find the most
expensive app in the game category
the world ends with you it seems
there you go
which is the most popular finance app so
basically we need to First filter by
Finance
so category is going to be Finance
and then it says with has the most in
install so we have to sort by installs
and that seems to be in finance the most
popular app which is kind of obvious I
hadn't thought about that is Google Play
Google pay sorry that makes total sense
and that captivity also passes
what team game has the most review so
what up from the game category and
catalog as teen in content rating so DF
at
contentrating.value counts
we haven't looked at all the content
ratings yet uh Team okay so what I find
we want to find the app from category
equals
game it seems
uh
category game
and content rating
equals teen
that's
and we're gonna find the one that has
the greatest number of reviews so the
maximum number of reviews and a sort
values
by reviews
ascending false
first five
Asphalt 8 airborne seems to me it seems
to be the most popular in terms of
reviews of all the games are of content
writing team let's take a look
yep that worked as expected
what paid game
has the most reviews
so we have to find a
game that's let's say let's use our
distribution column
column that is here paid
and has the most reviews and it's going
to be the same thing
um distribution paid and it's
again has most reviews price equals
greater than zero
by reviews ascending folds Hitman sniper
no because we probably need
and price greater than zero
what paid up from the game category
category gain has the greatest number of
reviews
what if
Clash of Clans Let's let me try this
because I found
an error
yeah so this activity
it should be what free game has the most
reviews so we have to fix that ideally
by the time you're watching this that
has already been fixed so let's keep
moving forward
finally how many terabytes we can
actually report an issue right here
for the previous one report an issue
the activity is asking for
uh
paid apps but the solution is for free
apps
okay submitting it just in case like
finally
how many
terabytes were transferred overall for
the most popular
lifestyle app and this is a very
interesting piece this approves the
greatest amount of byte transfer enter
the answering terabytes as a whole
number running down the nearest integer
example if you find the total transfer
to be 780 point just enter seventh
80. so the app most popular is going to
be DF dot query we're going to say as
usual category equals live Style
yes no what's the name
to live
style there you go sort values by
um
sort values by
by installs
is the one that produced it so this is
the app that was installed in more the
greatest amount of times like for most
times and we're going to do ascending
Falls
I'm gonna do I log zero right let me
show you thoughts first so Tinder was
the app with the most installs I do that
I locked zero so I get this first
row I'm going to show you up this is our
app and now we have to do app so this
app wants to install this many times and
the size is this size in bytes right so
that's going to be up at installs times
up
at
um size right but this is in bytes we
have to divide until we reach
terabytes is going to be kilobytes
megabytes
gigabytes
terabytes there you go
so let me show you the previous one
these many bytes this many terabytes
transferred and I think what do we have
we can we can actually do it in the the
following so six I think it's petabytes
so we can ask the assistance just in
between what follows after
Terra
bye
um so
basically this is the answer in
terabytes it says to just enter the
whole number rounding down so we're
gonna put just six four eight four
sorry go
and this is still working you can see if
we can answer
real quick
I think it's petabytes that follows
terabytes but it's a kind of well it
broke anyway the greatest
the app that produced the biggest amount
of data transferred in that case with
Tinder with 6 000 terabytes which I
think is 6.3
petabytes I think I'm not sure anyway
um this is a great project we did a lot
remember we started with the whole data
training process which as usual data we
had a lot of detective work we had to
find out why some of these columns were
incorrectly parse these objects so
suspicious we started removing things
turning to the metric as usual keep
trying to keep everything I think there
are two or three very important things
that I'm trying to transfer to you here
and the first one is that
um visit active work you know trying to
turn things to numeric and try to find
out where the issues removing things and
doing this iterative work the second one
is if you're modifying data frame always
keeping copies we were able to fix an
issue by keeping copy
um and then the third one is keeping
everything a string until you're safe to
turn it back into a number the same
thing is going to apply if you're
turning something into a date first you
know keep working as strength string
strings until you're ready to turn it
into a number but anyway I think this is
very interesting process also the same
the whole idea behind where the data is
coming from it was scraped so we were
finding the duplicate data we were
assuming that the app with the most
reviews was going to be the app with um
that was a freshest copy so doing all
this you know analysis based on our data
this basically a data science process so
if you are comfortable with this
congratulations because you're you're
pretty pretty pretty close in becoming a
data scientist
now for this project we're gonna combine
our data wrangling data cleaning skills
to finally perform some data analysis
using Group by operation so it's a
pretty interesting one the data that
we're working with the data we're going
to be analyzing is information about
Premier League matches the Premier
League is the top tier Top Flight
football soccer league in England
potentially in the world and the data
set we have has information about
matches from multiple Seasons starting
2006 2007 season
um and it's a very very interesting data
sets because we have the teams played
and the goals is scored and the final
results
so
um
anyway we're gonna start one by one with
the activities as usual I want you to
just pass if you want to resolve them by
yourself
um pause or resume password resume so
you see me perform the the different
activities and you can borrow some ideas
from my solution so let's get started
replace invalid values from the seasons
column and before we can replace invalid
values we have to identify the invalid
values to do so
we're gonna we're gonna take a look at
the seasons we're gonna do here value
counts
there you go I see that
um there are
2007 a 2008 nine nine ten Etc but then
we have this question mark here so this
one is one of the first examples of an
invalid value in a column in this case
um it's a string column here string
column and the invalid value comes
because this is a question mark and of
course it's not within the format of the
Season there is no enforcing in these
strings they're just strings but we can
see very clearly that there is a clear
pattern a format that is an integer Dash
an integer and of course the question
mark doesn't match that so we have to
claim those values and replace them with
the value unknown season to do thoughts
what we're gonna do is df.block
pass now if you want uh DF at season
equals question mark the season value
there we go all these values we're gonna
replace them with unknown season
and now
there should be removed
let's check the activity to see if it
works
it works so we can keep moving forward
identify invalid values in goals score
this is a pretty interesting one as well
because it deals with a little bit of
data cleaning but conceptually speaking
the the
data cleaning process like the decision
tree that I'm running in my mind is
different because to identify invalid
values and goals I'm gonna take a look
first again at the info method and you
can see that both home goals and Away
goals are integer numbers so that is
that is correct those are supposed to be
integers so how could we have an invalid
value here it'll be different if for
example we see an object here because
that means that pen has found something
that cannot be parsed as a ninja so it
turns it into a string right
um but in this case they're all integers
and that's pretty much the valid
now what we're gonna find is given that
the we have identified the value type
which is an integer and the column
itself is an integer
what is the next process what is the
same in the next uh decision we have to
make well if the data
in if the range of potential values is
met right so there are a few other
projects deal with some other things but
for example we have rainfall you know
that's something that can take a given
value we have for example Power electric
power in a house you know the the the
valid values are going to be between I
don't know zero and 110 115 but there
are valid values for everything and and
we have a range now as a second step to
define the validity of that column so to
do that what we're going to do is just
use a little bit of plotting to Aid in
the process of identifying the symbolic
values well UDF adds home home goals and
uploads kind first we're going to do a
histogram
and we can quickly see that there are
some values that are invalid because
they are below zero and in a football
match the minimum value the minimum goal
score is zero we don't see anything
weird on the right hand side we don't
see any stream goal count if we see
something like for example 20 25 30 that
is a little bit more difficult because
it's about it's valid in terms of a
range
but it's an outlier so
is there possibly a Premier League
football match in which where 20 goals
scored
I mean it's possible it's highly
unlikely and that's this the third step
and we have to start digging a little
bit more understanding value again
hopefully or thankfully
um in this case that doesn't happen I'm
going to turn this into a box plot so we
can visualize it I'm gonna
swap it to be horizontal I'm gonna do
vert Falls there you go and we can see
pretty much the same thing most of the
goals are going to be concentrated here
and we have a few samples below zero
that are invalid I'm going to add away
goals down
to visualize the way it goes and we can
also see like this is the the zero line
we can also see that there are a bunch
of invalid values right here
um interestingly the way goals are all
shifted to the left that means that home
teams tend to score more goals which
makes sense if you watch football or
soccer
um so we have pretty much understood the
invalid in like the validity of the
column we know it's an integer we know
that it has a range because we know the
sport and we have identified that there
are values that are outside of that
range so now we have to take a look at
them and hear what we're gonna do is
we're gonna do
um that are less than zero and we're
gonna sum
that's
and we have 34 home goals that are
invalid and 39 away goals are involved
sometimes people have issues with this
sort of thing that I did if you want to
think about it in a different way we can
do something idea if the lock
at home goals is less than zero
um um
or DF
uh away goals is less than zero we can
take a look here at
um at the different ones you know we can
start finding how many we have or
actually we could say something like
it's easier if we do something like
shape here or some here
we have only 34 but as this is this the
results of this expression is a data
frame we can do pretty much everything
all together
um and now to answer home goals invalid
34 away 39 so that's going to be
34 home goals 39 away goals and let's
check the activity
and it worked
now
moving on with the third activity it's
pretty much the same thing we did before
we're going to do DF dot lockdf at home
goals that are less than zero
we're gonna home goals we're gonna
that thing we're going to replace them
all with zeros we're going to do the
same thing with away goals
and we're gonna check the activity
and it worked
identifying cleaning valued results in
the result column and this is a very
interesting one because we can keep
looking at the different data cleaning
scenarios or techniques we have to
approach
we had one that we had just simple
strings and we had to find a pattern
there is a pattern year Dash year this
year is the year before in this year
right so there is N Dash n plus one a
four digit integer there was a a free
form pattern here and there was a pretty
clear file it was uh eval it was a
question mark we then jumped to a
integer which was the correct value type
or the correct type of value for goals
but then we had a given range that was
available it was valid and of course
there were values that were outside that
range which made it invalid finally we
have the one that we're trying to deal
with here which is the result one and
the the result column
it's interesting because what we're
gonna find
value counts
it took a little bit of time
um
the idea oh because Iraq autocompleted
but the idea is that value counts is
let's say a categorical variable it's
not let's say it's it's a categorical
variable the values that we can take
um in result are restricted it's either
age for a home Victory a for an away
Victory and D for a draw and that's it
anything outside of that range is
considered invalid and these are usually
the simpler to put in a way values to
not to claim but to identify at least
but we can quickly see if a vowel is
outside of this subset of potential
possible values these are the only three
possible values that is different again
from what we saw before with the seasons
because we have to apply a pattern here
this is just a free form string there's
a pattern underneath so we can have any
value we can have you know 1950 1951 for
example something like that so that's a
little bit more difficult but again in
this case it's pretty obvious that
everything that has a question mark
is an invalid result now how can we
clean that well we already have the the
we can already calculate this result the
result column is a calculated column
because you can just get that by uh
Computing the result yourself you know
one one is a draw if the value is here
and the value is here and the same if
there is a number an equal number of
goals that's a a draw if the home goals
are greater than the way goals that's a
home Victory and if they're way Victory
is greater than the
um home goals that is going to be in a
way Victory so how can we fix that
fairly easy we can do df.lock DF odds
for example home goals greater
than DF odds away goals
there you go this should all be all
these results should be we can do
assault
uh value accounts
all these results should be
um valid right so the the there should
all be sorry an H but we know not only
have this question mark we also have
invalid values because we can calculate
the results so this is why this is a
pretty interesting activity so now what
we can do is just here to
like step over the value and we know
there's going to be a home Victory are
we going to do the same thing for pretty
much every other possibility we can say
if away goals is greater than home goals
that's going to be an away when
and finally if
let's put here if home goals is equals
the way goals that's gonna be a draw
that's pretty much the same thing and
now we can count again
and we have the possible values let's
give it a try
and it works as expected all right
moving on to the analysis pieces when we
start doing some interesting analysis
with uh Group by activities and all that
so what's the average number of goals
per match and we don't have that value
goals per match we don't have it but we
can easily calculate it on the fly so
home goals
DF at away goals we have thoughts
um and we can sorry zoom out we can here
have the
average very quickly and the activity is
asking us calculate the average number
and put it with two decimals that's 2.66
if I'm not mistaking I'm not saying it
2.66 and the Activity Works
next one create a new column total goals
so now it's pretty much asking us to
create a new column the effort total
goals
by passing this thing
and
total goals there we go and we can check
the activity real quickly and in past as
expected
now calculate average goals per season
and we have to sort the values by by
season and we need to sort in the goals
per season variable so the way it's
gonna work is let me zoom in
what I do group by
Group by uh season and here we're gonna
get total goals
you're gonna get the mean
there I go we need to sort these by the
index that's the season name so that's
going to be sort in val sort index which
gives us the same result just we were
lucky enough and we can store that in
the goals per season variable
let's check the activity and see if it
passes
there you go it passed we are good to
keep making progress
what's the biggest goal difference in a
match and this is an interesting one as
well
why
we have two potential results when Hong
won or when away one right we have a
home Victory and Away Victory and we
have the difference of those two so we
have something like DF Arts home goals
um let's say minus TF adds away goals
and we can do here something like Max
right
we could do the same thing by doing away
goals and home goals
and then we have the maximum so this is
a maximum difference in the biggest goal
difference
for a home win and this is the biggest
goal difference for an away win
we could have used the same value here
to do something like
Max and Min and that's going to be -6
right because in this case it was an
away when the way side one and that
gives us a negative result
but basically if I don't care about the
symbol because basically what I care is
that magnitude of the value 8 or 6
that's a magnitude of the value then
what I could have done is just do
um it's something like uh do
absolute
there you go and now we can get the max
value or to put in a way we can just do
sort values
ascending false head we can get the
results here so anyway we arrived to the
same result using different techniques
basically the most interesting piece for
me at least here is for you
understanding the absolute method
because again it's 6 or -6 in this case
it's the same for us because what we
care about the magnitude the goal
difference we don't care if it was the
way team the one or the home team that
won right so the the absolute method
will give us that magnitude let's try
with eight anyways
um
it was pretty obvious that it was a home
win if you know a little bit about
football soccer those those are the case
Okay moving forward
what's the team with most away wins and
this is a very interesting one as well
why we could start doing something like
df.log DF art results is
um away right we have all the away team
away uh victories now we can group group
by the away team because basically what
it's asking us what's the team with the
most always win so this is an away win
um who was a team is basically away team
and now we can just uh results dot size
and we can get
oh we can sort values
by
um by
nothing because this series ascending
false
and let's do just head and we have that
the team with the most away wins is
Chelsea let's give it a try first and
then I'm gonna show you something
different a different way to calculate
this thing very good work
there's a different way and it's
actually the solution proposed here so
I'm just gonna go ahead and reveal it
um and we can I can I can just copy and
paste this thing so we don't waste so
much time and I can explain it to you
right here
basically what is happening here is we
can Group by the way team
and when we do this grouping we're gonna
have
uh head we're gonna have all the results
for an away team so for Liverpool we're
gonna have
um these results
and pretty much any other result from
Liverpool and that's going to include
draws home victories and Away victories
so basically what we want to do is we
want to grow we're going to get this
group that is
um let me get here lock if odds away
team is
Liverpool as they say
there you go so when we Group by away
team we can CR we create we create like
we have so we have this full data frame
that has for example Liverpool here and
Liverpool here and Liverpool here and
Liverpool here and it has a
let's do How can I
there has a monster city oh I got green
why
it's Monster City Manchester City
Manchester City and Manchester City
and and we can get another football team
from the Premier League can get here
wolves wolves is another team wolves
walls wolf walls
what the group by operation is gonna do
is gonna identify we're gonna use Block
it's gonna identify the valleys are the
same and it's going to pre-package them
right in this I don't know if you've
heard about it but the term is splits
apply combine it's gonna create tiny
groups with the different uh
samples that meet their grouping
criteria this is going to put all the
Liverpool all Liverpool matches here
it's gonna put
um all the Manchester City matches here
it's gonna put all the Wolves matches
here
it's going to give you the option now
to work with this thing so now we can do
for example now get me the the away
goals and do a sum
or give me the results and give me the
signs we can do any operation with these
groups and then it will assemble them
again in a table and it's going to say
Liverpool whatever Manchester City
whatever wolves whatever or Monster
United whatever you get it's gonna
combine all these more pieces that it
has created
but before we do the operation we have
the chance to run a custom function and
that's the apply one right here so we
can run we can pass this custom function
that is going to be run in each
individual group
and what the custom function does is it
gets all the rows so here's gonna get a
draw a and a way when a home win uh on a
way win
Etc and we're gonna perform the the
operation that we want which is counting
the ones that are on a way when so we're
gonna get only the ones that are in a
way when we're gonna do a sum and we're
gonna return that value so here's gonna
be two and here's gonna be for example
just one and here's Gabby is I don't
know zero okay I get just one finally
pandas by itself just takes care of
saying Liverpool to Manchester City one
and wolves
that's too many walls and zero
right the combination at the end and
that's the way that function Works let's
clear this whole thing unrun it
and we get
pretty much the same results as before
is
um Chelsea Manchester United Arsenal Etc
so the way to think about it is you can
filter your data before starting or you
can perform like these operations after
you have grouped the data with the
individual groups that you had before
okay that's it let's keep move forward
because we have just three more
activities to go what's the team with
the most goals scored at home
um so this is a pretty interesting one
as well let me get head
you take the time now to pass the
activity and solve it by yourself I
selected Chelsea I don't know why it's a
mistake but again take the chance to
pause and select and do it by yourself
basically it's asking what's the team
with the most goals scored at home so
it's basically the home team
we have to group by home team
home
team
uh we have to count this whole goals so
here we just count home goals how we
need now to get the sum
um when I get the whole thing but of
course we need to sort values by uh
sending
false and we're gonna get head
there we go
um and we have the Manchester City seems
to be the goal with most the the team
sorry with the most
home goals court so let's try that out
and that is correct a pretty a pretty
dangerous team in attack Manchester City
for sure especially now this is outdated
especially now
okay uh second to last what's the team
that received the last the least amount
of goals while playing at home and this
is also a very interesting one because
if I was just naive I was gonna do
something like
um
DF the team group
by
uh uh home team what's the team that
received the least amount of goals and
I'm going to be away goals so it's team
playing at home away goals
dot sum sort
values head
there you go so charton athletic only
received 20 goals right but the the
reality is that they only play df.log DF
or no let's do DF at home team equals
Chardon
uh very
there you go the sum
um they only play 19
games at home so
it's interesting because what these
activities asking us is for the ratio of
goals received over home games and I
think if you have not passed I think
it's a very very good moment to pause
and try to resolve it by yourself but
anyway let's just do it we're gonna
start first we're gonna keep the same
group by operation
but we will try to get two things we
will try to get the total goals they
received
and the
um total matches they played so we're
gonna get uh we're gonna get uh away
goals and we're also gonna get first
we're gonna get just here home team I
got two different operations for that
we're gonna use the aggregation method
and we're going to use a dictionary
we're gonna say
for home team perform the size operation
for away goals
perform the sum operation
let's take a quick look at what we have
there we go we're gonna sort values by
um by by
home team it's actually
ascending
false uh
uh by home team I did something wrong
here
my bad
sort
values by
home team
Y is
oh because it's both so let's replace
replace uh rename rename
uh columns we're gonna call home team
um total matches the total games I'm
gonna put away goals equals goals
received
there you go
um let's break this in a couple of lines
really quickly and
ascending false there you go
um
total games
no because this is total games now
games
there you go so Liverpool Tottenham so
these are The Usual Suspects right the
teams that have always played at the top
of the Premier League
um we can do now is sort by two things
we can sort by goal by Sorry by
total games and we can also sort by
goals received
but we want to flip the Sorting here we
want to get all the players that all
sorry all the teams that played a ton of
games so ascending Falls but then we
want to get the ones that receive few
goals so we're gonna be ascending true
and now we're gonna get the monster
United
um Manchester United is a team that
played the most games with the least
gold received we can let's say we can
rename this thing we're going to do
something like
um we're gonna call it
um games
per team games
home games
per team
and call that
head
[Music]
we could do something like
um
ratio what's gonna be it's gonna be uh
goals received per match
and we're gonna call this thing we're
gonna be the result of
homegoing games per team at goal
received
divided by
home games per team
at total games
and let me break this into multiple
lines so it's a little bit more readable
and now we're gonna do pretty much the
same thing as before but we're gonna do
is value
sort values
by
goals received per match
head
I get the same result just Manchester
United with the uh best ratio in terms
of goals received per match so actually
try it out because I haven't tried out
let's see if it's the team we're waiting
for that is correct correct value
basically what I'm saying here is that
we tried we first
God we have for La the same grouping
operation we computed two different
things total games sorry total gold
received
those away goals because it was a home
team but we also competed how many games
they played so same group by operation
if you allow me a very quick draw right
we have like the big chunk of teams and
then we did like this separation of
small small groups for home teams
um but then we competed two different
things for home team this gave us the
size for the way goals this gave us the
sum right some some all the way goals
and we did these two operations in all
the individual chunks to compute the
final results
um we quickly identify Manchester United
as the one meeting the requirement of
activity but we went one step further to
actually compute these goals received
per match value why is that because if
you want to make this thing analytical
and potentially automated we need it we
needed an analytical way
um what else there is I think we can
take a look I think there is a pretty
interesting solution here
now I thought that we had a solution
that had um
everything in a one-liner with a apply
operation it is potentially doable if
you want to give it a try
um but I think readability matters in
this case
and finally what's the team with most
goals score playing as a visitor away
from home and this is gonna be pretty
much the same thing as before
to buy away team
um and we're gonna get the team playing
away from home score more goals I'm
gonna get uh goals
go
um I forgot already the name of the
columns
it's away goals
away goals
away goals sorry and what we're gonna do
is some
get a preview
and now we're gonna do
a sort of values ascending Folds
and it seems to be Arsenal let's give it
a try
and it passed and we completed our
projects
so this was pretty much the the activity
we started with a little bit of data
cleaning data wrangling pretty
interesting because again we had a good
variety of different issues with our
data we had the issue of
um the the
invalid Seasons which is the string in
Violin pattern then we moved to the
invalid count of goals which is an
integer out of range then we claim the
categorical result variable it was just
a potentially just a result uh
categorical so their results should be
in this in this subset we had a way to
clean that but just calculating
something else in the data frame that
was a good thing and then we started
with a bunch of group by activities all
very interesting so take a look at
yourself if you want to replay it in
other case we have a bunch of other
projects dealing with data wrangling and
group I and all these operations
this is a very interesting project that
combines some data wrangling skills
which involves merging data frames
creating new columns with some data
cleaning skills and it's going to
require you to take a look at the data
and do some cleaning to make those merch
work and finally do some analysis some
question answering with Group by
operations with transform operations so
it's a very very interesting project for
sure a as usual I encourage you to pause
the video first try to resolve it by
yourself and then of course take a look
at the solutions because maybe I'm
choosing a different way of what you're
doing and you can see something
different so with all that said let's
just get started I have the first few
rows executed already as you can see
and let's take a look at the data that
we're going to be working with in this
case we're going to be working with NBA
basketball information and basically we
have the 2017 season stats that's going
to be in this data frame right here
which involves the usual you know just
information for each player as an
aggregate of the whole season and then
we have a players DF data frame that
includes
the personal information of the players
of their name their weight birthday
College Etc the important piece here is
that the players data frame contains
information about all the players in the
registered history of the NBA so that's
from like 19 and 50s the information in
the stats in the seasons only from 2017
so we're gonna start by doing a merge
but of course going to be an interesting
one because we have to merge in a
specific way
the first activity and here again
encourage you to just pause involves
merging data from the 2017 season with
the players but performing a left
showing so basically we want to include
here in our Seasons DF data frame we
will include the personal information
from the player we want to bring the
data to our existing data frame from
this particular season okay so as you
might remember there are different types
of merch to do we can do an inner we can
do a left or right outer we can do a
full outer in this case by performing a
left outer join we're gonna be able to
contain to like to keep all the
information from this data frame 2017
and bring only the matches from the
players DF data frame so let's go ahead
and do that again this is your your
opportunity to pause the video
um to do a merge what we're going to do
is we're gonna start with season 2017 DF
and we're gonna merge
merge with uh merge uh players DF
um and we have to first I'm gonna
players DF
we're gonna do a how left
because that's basically what it's asked
and again the reasoning is that we want
to keep all the information on the same
thing from 2017 DF and we're gonna pass
the Collins to March so on the left side
we're gonna pass the player and on the
right on we're gonna pass the name it's
the same information but it's two
different columns
um if you remember we have the on
uh on based attributes to referred in
individual columns and we also have the
indices if potentially you're emerging
per index in this case we're just using
the regular columns and we're going to
assign all this to data frame
and let's check the activity to see if
it passes
we can take a look at the the DF
um this is going to be a long data frame
I can actually show you something like
DF uh dot head and we're going to do
just the first row under a transpose so
you can see all the information right
here
so um we had let me potentially do a
little bit of a drawing if I'm allowed
here we're gonna select red
basically what we did is uh we didn't
select right there we go
so basically we have all the seasons
that we're gonna make like a long data
frame I'm gonna use uh blue to do the
players merge right there the resulting
the resulting merge that we can use
another color let's say here purple the
resulting are just gonna basically as
it's a left outer join and this is left
what we're doing is we're bringing this
data frame to the side here and
basically make it match with whatever
information we have in between so if in
the season 17 there were you know two
players were repeated we could have
potentially
um duplicated that data and that's
perfectly fine because if we have the
same player here two times because of
any reason because a player played in
two different seasons uh two different
teams in the same season we actually
wanna duplicate the the right hand
information in both of them because in
again what we're doing is we're
complaining with the personal
information of the player so say that
let's take a look at the whole data that
were where we have it's it's a large
data frame but what's going to give us
the key if the merge was successful
the important piece is the name because
sometimes you're going to find that some
columns are going to be nullable like
for example college nullable but this
doesn't indicate that the merge wasn't
successful this indicates that just
College was null but the name column is
not nullable so that means that if we
find a
a value a row in the DF variable that is
null in name that means the merge was
not successful so are there any misses
in that data frame and this is the
second activity
we can quickly take a look at that by
doing TF at name dot is an A and here we
can do for example any
any
this is true we can actually answer that
real quick and the next one is going to
ask us how many well we can do a sum
right there we can find there are four
missing uh four missing
players basically we couldn't much so
there are four people and I think now
it's gonna be a little bit more clear
once we visualize and there are four
four rows in the season data frame that
we couldn't March for a valid player
which is strange right because we know
that these players DF data frame
contains information for all the players
in the NBA so how is it possible we
couldn't match four players let's
actually take a look at those people and
that's
um the fourth activity that we have
right here that is extracting names
before we do so I just want to show you
who are these missing players so let's
take a look at the values in DF that's
are that have a none or a null value in
name and those are these four players
right here we're gonna take a look in a
second at these places and see why we
had at that mismatch so this activity is
asking us to basically find those four
people
it's asking us to put them in a list so
what I'm going to do is just going to do
that and I'm gonna plus here the player
and we're gonna do values and finally
I'm gonna make here a list
now player misses contains the list of
um players are missing we're gonna check
the activity
and it passed correctly
so this is a very interesting activity
and this is the one that I think is the
most representative of the data cleaning
process in general for any data
scientist data data analysts data
engineer which is actually fixing these
missing issues right and there are
sometimes different strategies sometimes
you can just delete the missing rows
because I mean if you have millions of
rows and there are a few that are null
you can just delete them sometimes you
can replace it with something else
sometimes you have to actually fix them
you have to realize like what happened
and just fixed it
and the way we're gonna do is just doing
some detective work and and this is just
perfectly normal in the whole data
engineering data science data analysis
process which is just taking a look at
your data and trying to understand with
domain knowledge and this is a very
important point with the main knowledge
trying to understand what went wrong and
domain knowledge is very important
because I can I can and we will actually
perform this this cleaning we're going
to fix these values but we need to
understand a little bit of what happened
with the basketball season the same
thing happens for example and I think I
have already put this example in another
project if I'm working for example in a
biology lab or in a physics lab in a
nuclear physics lab as a data scientist
there are going to be a ton of data
cleaning tasks that I will just not be
able to perform not because I don't know
the techniques because I'm very good
with pandas but because I need to
understand the domain that I'm working
on in order to be able to perform some
operations under understand my data
right so for example if you have no idea
about basketball and you feel and you
see a value for points that is a hundred
thousand
maybe that file is good for you but of
course it's pretty hard to make a
hundred thousand points in a season in
the NBA so by knowing the knowledge you
had you have just immediately
um placed the value in a in a given
range that of possibilities so your data
cleaning process it's a lot more it's
it's easier and it's more precise
because you knew the knowledge so the
same thing is going to happen here and
actually let's take a look at the
activity
and it tells us that with confidence and
I already know what activity says with
confidence it says that the players are
actually in players DF so there is
something wrong with players DF the the
right hand
um data frame so we're gonna players
df.here so there are some there is
something wrong with the names here that
somehow didn't match what we had in
player in the stats of the 2017 season
and the objective is to modify players
DF so they match whatever we had in the
um in the 17 20 20
17 season that's that's correct so let's
first identify where these players that
are in the 2017 season are not in the
player CF so basically we can make a
quick drawing here and potentially
so we have in 2017 we have
um this this guy look
which
is not potentially in the player ZF so
in the players the f
um the activity tells us for sure that
it's there we have to trust that for now
uh but these players like what name does
he have basically we have to find this
much
to do so one thing that I can do is just
and this is again a very detective work
um there are multiple ways of to
basically find this but I could do
something like let's keep it simple
maybe this player has a middle name and
that is part of the whole player's DF
but in the season that player wasn't
listed with that name so we can just go
ahead and do something like player CF uh
Dot Lock
and here I can do players player DF at
name
dots contains the same last name so
either any player in players DF that
contains this last name and we can find
the the given the given player what
happened in this case and we can just
take a look at what happened is that
this player either added a new surname
or always had the same surname but in
the 2017 season he was not listed with
this surname so we have seen we are
seeing like the first incompatibility
let's say so we can say that in players
players DF and we're gonna do
uh season 2017.
this player should be named should be
named we're gonna do that should be
named
um
the name in 2017 so we want that that
layer to be that name and we can keep
working you know with this detective
work
um maybe you know what happened for
example with maybe you don't know this
but Muhammad Ali was born Cassius Clay
and then he he switched religion or I
don't know how to say this but basically
he converted to Islam and he changed his
name to Muhammad Ali so the same thing
can happen to anybody we can change our
names and that's what happened here as
well so this person potentially goes by
a surname so for example Sheldon
McClellan which seems to be the original
name I can just go to Wikipedia uh born
Sheldon McLellan here here he is right
so the guy either changed his name or
just made it shorter we don't know to be
honest we don't care we have just found
another player with a different name so
I'm gonna add two thoughts so we know
that
um in
in the let's actually do Mac here
no uh Sheldon mark
where is
Sheldon Mark right here so in players.df
we we have shell and knock and we want
that player in the 2017 season it's like
well rewind it say what was the name
right in 2017 and that's the name
what who else James Michael let's take a
look at Michael here James Michael and
see if there is any changes there is a
new last name so again in players DF
this person is James Michael McAdoo and
we want this person to be renamed where
it's like we're rewinding the names 2017
and in at the end we have a meta world
and here I'm gonna do another trick take
a look at this and I'm gonna first lower
the names and then I'm gonna do
uh Meta Meta with a Double T
there we go and seems like meta world
was the name in 2017
uh but now it's something different so
we're gonna rewind again if you allow me
the expression
to the old name in 2017.
um we can store this names mapping there
we go
so we can keep the names as a reminder
and of course I'm missing the comments
as usual
as it will be the Puerto so how are you
we gonna do this thing well the way to
do it is just we're gonna find a player
in this case we're gonna find a player
with the with the same name so in this
case let's do it with uh the I don't
know first one
first name
so this is the player in player CF with
the full name we wanna rewind a player
back to the name in 2017
um and we want to take just name right
name and we want to assign that to the
name in uh 2017 so we can change dots
there you go
um if we don't emerge let's go ahead
really quickly I'm gonna zoom out let's
do the merge once again really quickly
and let's find the players don't match
which as you can see it's just three
because we fixed the first one so this
works what we can do now is we have four
but we can just automate quote unquote
this process let me re-read players
because I have modified Players let's do
the merge again let's go back to the
state where we have these four players
missing including look
um
and now we're gonna do this same process
but we're gonna automate it just we're
gonna use for Loop so we don't have to
type it one uh one by one and to the way
to do that it's gonna do four old name
or it's actually like um new name let's
say
and name 2017 so it's the new name and
the name they had in 2017.
in namesmapping dot items we're gonna
find the person we're gonna find the
person with a new name
and we're going to replace it with the
name
2017 Bali and of course I'm missing now
a Colin and there you go
we can now try we can check the activity
to see if we did everything correctly it
seems like it worked we can now perform
the same merge again and see how it goes
just let's take a look so I'm gonna copy
these cells same merge and we we know
what the activity is going to check but
we can borrow this cell and try it again
and see if we had any misses
no misses so this will potentially
there you go it worked as expected
okay remove unnecessary columns this
just again data wrangling very boring
just you know we have to get rid of a
few columns as I show you
um the first row transpose there are a
ton of columns we're not going to be
using so what we can do is just drop
these columns how to drop the eftop drop
is the method columns
columns to to drop in place equals true
because we want to modify data frame and
now we're going to check the activity
and it works
rename teams to their foreign names this
is a very interesting one because it has
a very simple solution
um but it's usually not expected I see
some some very crazy solutions for this
sort of activities that involve our
renaming
basically we have
um the team of the player is a three
letter acronym we wanna
Resort back to the full name of the team
to do so what we can do is the replays
method so we can do DF at Team dot
replace and we can use this mapping that
was given for us team mapping
um there and you can I'll just execute
this thing
and it didn't work because it's actually
a team that I go TM so we're replacing
one by one these acronyms whenever you
have OKC it's gonna find here OKC it's
gonna replace with Oklahoma City Thunder
um we're gonna find for example d-a-l
it's gonna look for Dallas where is it I
don't know where it is basically where
is that that last second one so
basically it's gonna it's it's just a
mapping and it replaces one by one and
we can store this result right in the
column team that's gonna be it so we're
gonna do DM dfr team
which is the full name it's going to be
this column with a replace mapping
performed and now we can do the F let's
do DF at
player
TM and team let's get first 10 rows and
we're gonna find ten rows and I find a
few things so
Indina Pacers SAS San Antonio Spurs
m-i-n Minnesota Timberwolves so this
looks okay and see what happens here
with this tot in a second
um but for now this is good
and let's check the activity to see if
we did the correct thing
and there you go it's working
convert birthday to a daytime object so
this is another interesting one
um the birthday of the player is a
string we're going to convert that to a
date to a to um time sum or daytime it's
very simple in pandas but we're gonna do
is PD 2 day time and we're gonna pass
directly the birth date
column
dots but of course this is an immutable
operation it's just returning a new
series what we want to do is just step
over whatever value we had before and of
course this is a change but you cannot
undo so easily so in this case we are
safe to just oh like step over the
previous values if not you can just
create a new column you know in this
case we're safe we can just re convert
the column back to
um daytime we can check the activity and
that worked as well
so going back again to the previous
violence that I showed you we had let me
borrow this thing here
um delete all players from the tot team
the tot is
for the players and that's actually
let's do something
um DF at
at
let's look for duplicate players
GF dot lockdf at
um player
dot duplicate it
um yes and we're gonna find we're gonna
duplicatus I wanna now
here
only these columns keep
false
sword values these are long operation
but don't worry it's pretty simple
um sore values by player
Ted Ken there you go long operation
some players in a given season can
switch teams right just right in between
there is a there's a chance for a window
and they can switch teams so you have
the first the same player sorry like
this guy right here that play for both
Cleveland and Dallas right in the same
season he was transfer in the middle of
the season so this data that we have and
we have to understand again the data set
we have
includes kind of an aggregation column
which is the tot column for totals so
totals of this person within the whole
season is so many field goals so many
three pointers so many free throws Etc
just a total an aggregation of the
season for this particular player we
need to get rid of that so I'm gonna do
that and oh actually we can use the same
no we can't use same condition how we're
gonna get rid of these um of these
values
first let's keep a copy because I mean
we're gonna be we're gonna be
breaking things so we need to keep a
copy we're going to do a DF copy
DS a copy this is a very common
technique when you're modifying
something as usual I encourage you not
to modify things but if you are certain
you want to get rid of something
um you can while you're doing the
process of understanding and Analysis
and all that you can create a quick copy
of your data if it's not large enough to
fill the whole memory of course because
because you're literally copying value
so if your data frame takes one gigabyte
of memory
you once you duplicate it now you have
two gigabytes of memory uh allocated so
as long as that's possible you can keep
a copy and I usually do like copy one
two three four five and that's pretty
much the data wrong process until you
figure things out and you're sure then
you can remove all the copies and of
course automate the work but for now we
keep a copy if anything goes wrong let
me comment this thing out so we don't
accidentally execute it we have a copy
in the F underscore copy
go back to the activity we have to get
rid of the players that have a tot team
so df.log DF at Team
um is equals tot all these players we
have to get rid of them
how can we get
um rid of them
there are multiple ways the easiest is
probably also with drop maybe not the
easiest because the easiest could be to
just do something like DF equals
the f equals uh
uh all the players that don't have a tot
and actually let's try it out and this
should work for both
except and doing something wrong it
worked
um but let's bring back the old data
frame if copy
copy there we go so we have it as it was
before I'm gonna delete the cell so I
don't
um accidentally execute it
and there is another way which is
basically we can find all these all
these
um rows right so all the rows we want to
get rid of and we can get the indexes so
the index of the rows when I get rid of
and finally we can use the drop method
so we're gonna get rid of these values
and we can do in place
true
and let's see if that works as well well
I have to reset all activities but trust
me that's also gonna work
all right like we have pretty much the
whole process done we merged the data
frame we found there were a few
mismatches right where the names of the
players changed so we roll in back the
South and 2017 doing some investiga
investigation work some detective work
we brought back to 2017 merch data get
rid of the columns created readable
names
um do a little bit more cleaning
removing tot and all that and now we're
gonna actually start with the analysis
so this is going to be very interesting
so um what's the team with the most
players in the league so we have again
so we have
um information about all these players
they work all these
um players in the 2017 season and of
course we know that some players
switched teams right so how many uh what
team had the most players within a
season either if they went back and
forth they changed a lot want to answer
how many which was the team with the
most players in a given season that's
pretty simple because we can just do a
value count
accounts and that's to head
and it's gonna tell us that the New
Orleans Pelicans was the team with the
most players to 27 in general register
players and that's correct
so what's the team with the lowest field
goals
um
let's take a look at the date again so
you understand what we're trying to do
here for each player for each row so
each row is a player in the 2017 season
we have merged that with our personal
information which we don't need in this
activity but basically we have field
goals that the Players Court in that
given season
so we want to aggregate
all the field goals of a given team of
all their players and find the one with
the lowest value for that
to do so we're gonna we're gonna Group
by team
team
and we're gonna find the field goal
column we're gonna sum that column
of course this is a mess so by basically
we're gonna do sort values by survival
is by nothing because just a series and
it's going to be ascending
we can actually do a head method here
I wanna
that's so it doesn't switch and we find
the Dallas Mavericks with the team that
scored the least to put it away field
goals in the 2017 season by just
Computing the aggregation of all its
players stats let's answer its
and that worked as correct
what is the team with the best feel goal
percentage and this is a very
interesting one because field goal
percentage is defined as field goals
divided by field goals attempt that is
data we actually have let me show you
again the values
so we have we have field goals 134 over
341 attempts so it's a little bit less
than 50 percent right you you tried 341
times to score and you only made 134 so
you made
134 divided by 341 your accuracy to put
it away was 0.39 or 39 percent so that's
the column that we want to compute
that's a value we want I can we want to
compute
but we want to compute this by team so
we have to aggregate all the field goals
and all the field goal attempts from a
team
and then
find that given
um percentage so we can start by doing
pretty much the same thing we did before
it's going to be DF Pro Group by team
and here we're gonna compute two values
we're going to compute field goals and
field goal attempts and we're going to
do some of these two
and
this method doesn't exist because I
missed type missed type that group by
there you go I gotta find this thing so
we can we can store this this data frame
in a partial variable saying uh field
goals per team
and field goal field goal per team okay
pre-visual assets and now we can compute
a new column which is going to be
uh it's going to be field goal
percentage which is equals to field goal
per team of FG divided
fga and now what we can do is sort
values by uh field goal percentage
head
and we're gonna find that
um with best so we need to do ascending
ascending false so the best field goal
percentage
is Golden State Warriors
let's try the activity first
let's find 2017 season
MBA
um who was the champion
um playoffs
Western Champions finals Champions
goalness and Wars so it's not uh it's
it's not a triviality that the the
player with the team with the best with
the best
um percentage won the championship
um anyway
let's take a look at the one with the
worst or you know the the lowest which
it's not us but just for the sake of
um of curiosity we can find that Memphis
Grizzlies de los Mavericks those where
the teams with the least accuracy to put
it in a way
okay so what's the difference between
the best and worst three-piece shooters
by position
it is known that shooting guards are the
best 3p throwers three-pointer throwers
by efficacy or accuracy the question is
what's the difference in accuracy with
the wars 3p throwers always considering
by position you note use the position
from POS column
so we're gonna Group by position now
and we're going to compute both three
pointers and three pointers attempts I'm
gonna sum all this and this is pretty
much the same thing that we did with the
previous one but in this case we're
doing it by position let's store that in
a variable so we're gonna say position
three pointer accuracy
we're gonna store that
and now we can create the new column we
know it's uh three pointer
percentage let's call it it's gonna be
three pointer
divided by 3pa
the attempts
and now we can do position 3p accuracy
now let's sort
values
um by three p percentage ascending false
the best position shooting guards as
expected again this is just domain
knowledge in basketball the shooting
guards are usually the ones shooting
better I could have with a better
accuracy
um
but it's telling that that we actually
need to find is what's the difference
inaccuracy between shooting guards and
the worst position the worst position in
the data frame which we found was the PF
power forward position right so what's
the difference in accuracy well we could
do something like this minus
dots it's going to give us the
percentage or we can do something like
um dots uh three p percentage dot Max
minus the one in min
and now we have pretty much the same
value without hard coding the difference
is 0.024 so in percentage terms that's
going to be 2.4 percent that's basically
this value right here
tiny difference right like from the best
position to the worst position and it's
not a huge difference but of course with
so many attempts it actually adds up
potentially in the league
all right so this is a very interesting
activity I seriously encourage you to
just pass here and try to resolve number
15 by yourself because a very
interesting one it might involve a ton
of Googling uh from you because I mean
it's not trivial so just you know this
is your use your chance to go ahead and
pause the activity try to solve it pause
the video sorry try to solve it by
yourself I'll give you one second then
we're gonna resume and I'm gonna solve
it live right here so you can see how I
approached the problem
all right let's take a stop at it
the activity is asking us to find the
best score per team right so we want to
basically generate this table that it's
the name of the player the team position
on the total points right so or not best
course in terms of you know just amount
of score points in their team so
basically
um we're gonna do something like for
example df.log DF at team is
um Oklahoma
and we're gonna get
um
I'm gonna get uh
points.mox so basically the max core
points in Oklahoma is this amount and
now we're gonna find where I find the
player by saying
um
these
and
DF at uh pts equals
that value
a number
and we found that that was Russell
Westbrook
um we can pretty much put everything in
just a one liner so we're gonna do I'm
gonna copy this thing here and I first
find Max points
in Team Max point in teams
um I'm gonna team is gonna be
uh DS at TM dots
I don't remember the okay Cleveland OH
which one no we were gonna do Boston how
is Boston's probably BOS
POS is it
just try it out
Boston BOS there we go to Android BOS
ston
and we're gonna do here team
team and then I find that the team is
team and this is Max points it's
corporate team
and
is
the best scorer of Boston so
I want you to understand the problem
this is not the solution we're gonna use
because I mean it involves a ton of
manual work per team we could
potentially just iterate you know
get all the teams we I can actually show
that to you so we can do something like
four
um team in
peer
dot unique
unique
um we're gonna do thoughts we're gonna
replace here team we're gonna place here
team
um prints
um we're gonna get here two things we're
gonna get player
I'm gonna get uh
team
there you go it gets uh the values I'm
gonna get player
team sorry for my variable names I'm
gonna do print
um I actually can get points as well
PTS
uh pts my variable names are terrible
we're gonna use we're gonna say P for
team
with PTS
I did something wrong
Pierre player team
df.log
uh not enough valuesome pack we're gonna
do
print this thing break
uh
potentially
what if I do this
okay I'm doing something definitely
wrong here which I can understand but
basically what I want to say is that we
can potentially do these manually right
so let's let's just print this thing
let's print
uh print this thing
um so Russell Westbrook for Oklahoma
with this amount of uh points Horizon
Burns for Dallas Mavericks with this
amount of of points
um let's see Houston
again it's a we can solve it manually so
Denver Nuggets Denver Nuggets Nikola
jokic you call a joke is foreign we
could potentially solve it manually but
the solution that I want to show you and
it took me some time solution I want to
show you
involves a group by operation to put in
a way and sorry because I'm drawing you
lately
um I'm gonna show you a drawing
signifying or or trying to explain the
solution that I'm going to use so
basically we have a our full data frame
so we're gonna use black as a data frame
there we go there is actually a way
that I can make this thing a whiteboard
there you go so we're gonna do this is
our data frame
and our data frame contains information
about different players and let's say
that we have red for Oklahoma
we have or no let's actually do red for
Chicago
of course we're gonna use uh we're gonna
use
um
blue for Oklahoma
and we're gonna use green grain
for
uh Boston I need a darker green
crane for Boston
um and the way it's gonna work is we're
gonna have these players are just
intertwined in the whole data frame
right so uh there you go and let's say
that right here this is the best shooter
or the best shooter in the given team
we're gonna have the same thing for
for Chicago we're going to have this
player and that player and that player
and that player and it's gonna be the
best scorer in the in in the in the team
and then we're gonna have this player
from Oklahoma and this player this
player and the player from Oklahoma this
is gonna be the best next actually put
it put that player here that's gonna be
the best from each team so that's
basically what B did in their previous
solution we filter we said in the
previous solution the manual one we've
created an intermediate data frame that
only contain uh players from a given
team Oklahoma in this case we then found
the best quarter with this value or
actually this value right here and we
made a second filtering in which we said
find D player
in that team with that amount of points
so now we have a single player
we wanna this is of course a different
solution what we want to do now or let's
separate it
what I do now is using a group by sort
of way operation we want the we want pen
this to focus on different groups of
players so for example all the blue
players all the green players all the
red players and perform an operation in
a group button Group by fashion but
we want it to the result expanding back
to the whole group
so we want it to just do that's pretty
similar we're gonna
focus on the blue players from Oklahoma
we're gonna do
create the group by operation the the
split piece
find something in this case we're going
to find the maximum in points so it's
going to be for example these maximum
points but instead of what we did before
which is all manual we wanted to go back
and replicate this value we're going to
call this value V
this value V very important we want it
to replicate it back to all the members
of the group so we want this value to be
applied here
and here
Etc so we want to we want it to be is
going to be V
and V and the same thing for any other
group that we have so for Chicago now
we're going to do another data frame
it's block we're going to do another
data frame
and we're going to do player player
player player that's all gonna be done
automatically by pandas fine the given
value we want in this case is V again
and just replicate that value V
V
here and of course the value you want to
find is the maximum of pts so the column
pts when I compute the maximum value and
then each player is going to have their
score so I don't know 900 points or 300
points whatever and next to it there's
going to be a new value that is going to
be the top of that group given the group
by operation here is going to say I
don't know a ton of points
1500 right so we want each player this
is going to be
300 and next to it is going to be 1500.
and there's going to be 30 point player
didn't even play and there's gonna be
1500 right and of course this one is
going to be 1500 in the in the
points and 1500 in the values
then what we're going to do is we're
going to just find the top player or the
player with the top points per per team
all right let's get rid of that
and finally resolve the task which is
relatively simple
I mean there was a huge explanation but
trust me it's simple the way we're going
to do it is we're gonna Group by
team
if I show you the drawing again it's
like we want a group by a team we want
to perform this operation here and this
operation here for each team
we're going to group by team
but we're gonna get a pts the column we
want to compute but here we're going to
apply the operation transform
and pass the value Max
and that's going to give us a value and
that's basically what I told you before
for each team for each group for each
individual so it found it found it first
broke the players into different groups
based on their team
it's found the value we were looking for
pts Max it's uh assigned the value to
each one it found the value put the
value next to each one of this and
reassemble the same data frame and now
we're going to have this value once
again so let's hide that and we're going
to do DF at uh best score
per team
is going to be that thing we're going to
assign it we can call it this is our V
value of course I want to use a better
variable name
and now we're going to look at let's say
DF at team is uh Oklahoma City Thunder
Oklahoma City and we're gonna find only
uh player and we're gonna find
um Team if you want repeat it on PTS
values by PTS
ascending false
first rows and here
you have that for oh oh of course I'm
I'm forgetting the most important column
we computed
there
well I find that all the players in
Oklahoma City
are now have now assigned these new
column which is best core per team which
is equals to the maximum value of pts
from their group so this is a very very
interesting functionality from pandas
the transform method basically it's like
group a group by operation so all your
data Group by operation split compute
apply and then reassemble back the whole
thing don't end up with different groups
so before all the operations was like
OKC Chicago Boston and a result in this
case goes back again to the previous
shape of the data so we can basically
create this transform data frames
um to compare
it an individual with third group
so this is what we have we can compare
that with Boston now
for example we can do the same thing for
Chicago I'm just
I'm showing you so in Boston the best
score was uh almost 2200 in Chicago it
was uh 1800 and you can basically see
that each player has a pts value and
then
um of course compared to the best car in
the team
finally how what we need to do and I'm
going back into what the activity is
asking is finding the best score per
team so that's basically finding all the
players which have a pts equals to best
corporate team so that's gonna be the
f.block DF at pts is equals to DF odds
best score per team and we need to get
the values player
team
position and PTs of course
um let's do that real quick
it's not the same thing it doesn't look
like the same thing because if we look
at the description it says that it
should be sorted by PTs in descending
mode so now we're gonna do sort of
values let's break this thing before it
starts
showing that annoying scroll
sort values by PTS
ascending false
first few rows Russell Westbrook James
Harden so we have the same results it
seems we finally need to store this
thing
in a variable
let's print the whole thing and you can
see that now the table looks pretty much
the same way as before even four near
looks pretty much the same way let's
check the activity just
as a node on the side at this point
because we did a pretty long
developments and that worked as expected
okay we have the final activity cleaning
the data frame The Notebook a little bit
which team has the youngest Squad by
average player age and this is a very
interesting activity because there are
two forms of solving it
um the first one
is gonna involved let me show you first
how we we actually computed birth date
as a daytime before so this is from the
players DF and we turn into a birthday
this is very easily solved by doing
um I know just giving you the answers
right away
um DF dot uh Group by
group
by birth uh team team
at birthday
dot meaning
and of course I made another typo here
broke by
and let's just sort the values
um
there you
go
um
and the interesting piece here I don't
know if you are noticing this right away
is that this operation that seems like a
very mathematical operation of computing
the average or the mean
was actually applied to a daytime object
right so that is that is pretty
interesting because Day times
um are not numbers per se they're just
points in time but basically what pandas
is doing is finding the that birthday is
kind of in a timeline I'm finally
Computing the the mean
which is the youngest team well it's
based it's basically the team that has
the greatest
to put in a way the the the latest birth
date right so
0314 is the
um latest date birth date mean third
um
um birthate right so if if we do
something like
like let's let's put this in in
timestamp
dot now
let's put this in in days right so
basically or actually let's put this in
years
uh days there you go so the average age
and of course this is 2017. we can
actually do that we can say this to 2018
0101 it's the same thing this doesn't
change anything uh timestamp there so
the the the team Portland for the trail
trail blazers Portland has the youngest
Squad by average right because basically
the average age was 25
years not days because we're we're
dividing by 365. so 25 years
was the average
age of the Portland Trail Blazers and
two concepts here I want to separate in
the first one and sorry the second one
that I mentioned was that we are here
finding the youngest team that's
basically the greatest date right if I
was born in I was born in 1987 my
brother was born in 1992 he has a newer
birth date like most more recent but
that makes him younger right I have a an
older date date a lower value right 1987
is lower than 1992 but that's makes that
makes me older that makes him younger
right that's that's the second thing
that I mentioned very quickly the first
thing which is the most important one
is that let's get rid of that is that
the birth date column is a daytime and
we correctly had a mean competed for
that will be the alternative and
actually let's try the activity
that works what is the the alternative
and I think we have that listed in the
solution is
let's say this didn't exist we'll
basically need to transform the date
back to a number and we can say let's
say dates
um we can say
age in days we have to transform this
thing from a date to a number so we can
say VF at age in days and we can say
PD let's actually let me actually show
you the the result first DF at birth
dates
minus or actually the other way PD dot
timestamp we said uh
um
dot now minus dots
that gives you a time Delta that's the
the name of the value pandas time Delta
I'm gonna
I'm Googling it real quick and we can
find a time Delta it's just a relative
duration of time and that is the the
time Delta and we can get for example to
be very precise we can get total
seconds
right
um total seconds DT total seconds or we
can get something like days and here
what I'm doing is a DT daytime accessor
so if uh pandas series a column in a
data frame is of time if a is a daytime
or a Time Delta it has a special
accessor.dt that lets you perform some
Daytime calculation on it similar as
with uh for example the F uh team.str we
have the Str accessor for string columns
we have the DT accessor for daytime and
time Delta columns or series
so anyway we can say
um this thing
H in
will probably will not say it so we say
we say player we say
um birth dates
and we are gonna say h in days
birth
dates
there you go so someone that was born in
0801 so August 1st is 10 899
893 days old so now we have transformed
the daytime back into a numeric column
and we can now compute the
um the average age so we can say Group
by same thing team
at age in days
uh dot mean sort values
and I did something wrong as usual group
I don't know why I have so many issues
with this group by the name
and now what you can see is that we
actually have to think the result in an
opposite direction now the lowest value
is the youngest one of course the
previous one was the the the day the
most recent date gave us the youngest
um Team now the team with the lowest age
in days is of course the youngest team
that's basically what we're finding
right here and we have let me clear this
whole thing so we can compare
uh birth date and these aging days we
have the same results ideally Portland
try let me actually sort it
sword
um ascending false so we compare the
values and we have Portland Portland
Toronto Toronto Boston Boston Orlando
Orlando it's the same value for both I
think the interesting takeaway here is
how pandas implements all these useful
daytime modifications modifiers methods
and even these operations I think that's
the most interesting piece so far so
again rubbing it up this project
extremely interesting because we did
pretty much the full cycle we
got the data we merged we identified
invalid values using this detective work
finding what happened rewinding time uh
we did some Googling we finally did some
cleaning transformed data types like
birth date then we did
um all these you know merging of the
data there you go deleting these totals
understanding data we were working with
and finally we did all these analysis my
favorite activity is by far the number
15 one with the transform method
extremely useful method so if you want
to replay it just you know try to solve
it by yourself
um and I think I think this project
represents very well the whole process
of data science data wrangling data
munging data engineering everything
you're gonna find in a in a regular
project dealing with data